bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
sur public SNA ce matin nous vous
proposons de revoir la discussion qui a
démarré hier après-midi à la Haute
Assemblée autour du projet de loi de
Cécile Duflot sur le logement et un
urbanisme rénové la ministre du Logement
a tenu à rassurer d'entrée de jeu hier
après-midi les sénateur autour de la
compétence des maires en matière de plan
local d'urmananisme vous le savez les
maires les sénateurs représentent les
maires le projet de loi prévoyait à
l'origine de transférer cette compétence
des maires en matière de plu aux
intercommunalités fronde chez les élus
locaux fronde chez les maires du coup un
amendement de la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat prévoit maintenant
de toujours réserver cette compétence en
matière de plu au maire et de la
transférer d'ici un délai de 3 ans aux
intercommunalités donc tout ça va faire
dans la douceur et dans des conditions
qui vont être précisées lors de la
discussion ici en 2e lecture de ce
projet de loi au Sénat alors ce matin je
vous propose de revoir la fin de la
discussion générale autour de ce projet
de loi et le début de l'examen autour de
l'article 1er du texte sur le logement
très bonne séance à tous sur l'antenne
de Public Sénat la parole est à madame
la
ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président de
commission messieurs les rapporteurs je
vais essayer de de répondre de manière à
la fois précise mais sans doute un peu
ramassé aux différentes interventions je
voudrais vous dire Monsieur le Sénateur
dylain que vous avez rappelé dans votre
intervention une chose essentielle que
je n'ai peut-être pas assez dite dans la
présentation de ce projet de loi c'est
combien ce projet de loi est nourri de
travaux parlementaires est nourri de
proposition de loi et nourri de rapports
parlementaires vous avez évoqué la
question des copropriétés dégradées sur
laquelle vous avez eu aussi la
gentillesse de bien vouloir me remettre
un rapport c'est une loi qui reprend
beaucoup de dispositions sur lesquelles
les parlementaires et notamment les
sénateurs avaient travaillé donc je
voudrais dire à quel point je suis
reconnaissante à l'ensemble des
parlementaires qui ont travaillé sur des
dispositions qui certaines d'entre elles
avaient été dans des projets de loi de
l'ancienne majorité qui n'avit pas
abouti notamment sur les questions
relatives aux professions immobilières
donc vous avez eu raison de le rappeler
c'est effectivement une vraie source de
de ce projet de loi monsieur le
rapporteur Berry Desbat il vous a été
rendu hommage ainsi que au président de
la commission j'y reviendrai sur le
travail de synthèse et le vrai travail
d'élaboration parlementaire et je fais
le lien avec la toute dernière
intervention qui est celle du sénateur
Bourquin sur cette question du plui et
je je n'ai qu'à me féliciter et je veux
le dire à chacune et chacun d'entre vous
du point sur lequel nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui je sais à quel point
l'inquiétude était forte et vous m'avez
vous avez eu la gentillesse quelques-uns
d'entre vous de me remercier mais je
voudrais dire que j'ai parfaitement
compris j'ai compris et et je le dis de
manière posée j'ai aussi entendu les
interventions d'un certain nombre de
sénateurs UMP tout à l'heure à quel
point ce sujet qui est un sujet
essentiel pour l'avenir de nos
territoires et pour le travail de nos
élus pouvait faire l'objet d'une d'une
bataille stérile et veine et à quel
point il était nécessaire que ce sujet
soit pris en compte en respectant les
inquiétudes même si pour certaines
d'entre elles elles pouvaient
m'apparaître oou elles sont apparu
infondé au aux députés et c'est pourquoi
la la disposition s'est trouvée dans le
projet de loi amendé par l'Assemblée tel
qu'elle elle était avant le travail en
commission mais j'étais non seulement
sensible mais j'étais volontaire et
c'est l'esprit du gouvernement d'être à
l'écoute des sénateurs et je veux vous
le dire ici puisque je sais que vous
avez évoqué cette question du
bicamérisme et j'y suis très attaché je
pense que et je le dis avec une grande
franchise je pense que cette loi sera
plus robuste plus forte plus précise
plus intelligente une fois le travail
parlementaire effectué qu'elle ne l'a
été au moment où la ministre que je suis
la présenté au nom du gouvernement je
pense que c'est toute la force du
travail parlementaire qu'elle doit
beaucoup aux uns aux autres mais qu'elle
doit beaucoup à votre travail monsieur
le rapporteur et que vous avez su
trouver euh les voix qui répondent à
l'objectif que défend le gouvernement
celui de considérer que la bonne échelle
est et l'échelle intercommunale mais en
aucun cas de laisser du crédit à l'idée
qu'on voudrait imposer aux élus locaux
une vision supracommunale et bien que ce
soit eux qui aient la main sur euh leur
avenir et que euh la disposition qui a
été adopté en commission et que je dis
ici avec un peu de solennité à
l'ensemble des élus sur tous ces bans ce
point d'équilibre cette volonté de
respecter non seulement le travail des
sénateurs mais l'inquiétude des élus
locaux qu'ils ont pu relayer je défends
endrait cette position devant les
députés je le dis je je le
dis
avec avec simplicité bien sûr je suis
éminemment respectueuse de la démocratie
ce seront les députés qui voteraient
mais je ferai tout ce qu'il est possible
de faire pour expliquer le sens d' de
cette position et aussi pour expliquer
je crois le sens d'une loi qui je le
souhaite et c'est en tout cas un vœux
que je formule à cet instant et avant
que nous commencions à débattre article
par article de ce projet de loi donc
j'espère que elle sera adoptée par les
deux Chambres ce qui montrerait aussi
que cette priorité en faveur du logement
est consacrée par l'ensemble des
parlementaires et n'est pas seulement un
sujet dont les uns se dessaisissent au
profit des autres je suis très attaché à
cette démarche et je voudrais
sincèrement remercier celles et ceux
d'entre vous qui ont su aussi dépasser
un certain nombre d'aprioris initiaux
pour travailler dans un climat de
confiance je les en remercie très
sincèrement et je tiens à dire monsieur
le rapporteur pri desbac vous avez été
vraiment au cœur de ce travail madame la
rapporteur archambau a euh présenté un
certain nombre d'avancé euh au nom de la
commission des affaires sociales mais je
voudrais ici rappeler que un certain
nombre de ces avancées d'autres qui ont
été amené par voie d'amendement mais un
certain nombre d'entre elles sont
simplement la traduction euh du plan de
lutte contre la pauvreté pour
l'inclusion sociale que le premier
ministre avait annoncé il s'agit donc de
la traduction d'engagement pris dans un
cadre partenarial avec les élus locaux
et avec les associations du gouvernement
euh ce travail avant
il est souvent nécessaire de rappeler et
de vérifier si les engagements pris sont
tenus tous les engagements relatifs à
l'hébergement et à l'accès au logement
pris à l'issue de cette conférence sont
tenu à la fois dans le cadre budgétaire
mais aussi dans le cadre
législatif monsieur Fichet a présenté
deux sujets essentiellement dans son
intervention une un relatif à la loi
littorale sur lequel nous reviendrons
plus longuement je pense dans le cadre
du débat et un autre sur la question des
sites et sol pollué je sais que là aussi
des travaux parlementaires trans
partisans partisans ont été portés sur
ce sujet je suis disposé à ce que un
certain nombre de ces propositions
recueille un avis favorable du
Gouvernement pour qu'elle puisse être
utilisée par les élus locaux monsieur
vaniren donc vous avez très utilement
fait le lien avec plusieurs lois la loi
le branchu et la loi le
fol vous avez parfaitement raison
puisque je serais amené dans la ma
réponse je serai amené pardon dans la
réponse à un certain nombre de vos
amendements à dire qu'effectivement un
certain nombre de sujets ont vocation à
être traité dans les deux autres lois de
décentralisation porté par ma collègue
marieelise Lebranchu ou dans la loi
d'orientation agricole portée par mon
collègue Stéphane Lefol il faut le
savoir et je le dis là ici avec beaucoup
de simplicité que nous avons réellement
travaillé ensemble donc ce n'est pas un
engagement de principe que je vous donne
mais un engagement sérieux en ayant la
volonté de considérer qu'un certain
nombre de disposition je pense à vous je
regarde vous tout particulièrement
Monsieur le Sénateur Labé parce que je
sais que vous portez des dispositions
qui ont réellement vocation à s'intégrer
dans cette loi mais c'est un avis qui
est partagé par mon collègue Stéphane
lefolle et donc ce seront ça n'est pas
une réponse dilatoire mais ce seront
bien des questions qui seront prises en
compte je le dis parce que nous aurons à
revenir dans le débat sur la question de
la préservation des terres agricoles
madame bourset vous avez fait référence
à ces sujetsl je pense qu'il est très
important d'être mobilisé sur ce sujet
et de trouver alors je sais que nous
aurons un débat assez intense sans doute
sur ces questions un point d'équilibre
dans nos travaux parlementaires parce
que je le dis notamment de la part des
syndicats agricoles je pense en
particulier aux jeunes la pression est
extrêmement forte le sentiment est que
la situation s'aggrave s'aggrave dans
les territoires les plus tendus et que
les difficultés d'installation pour les
jeunes sont de plus en plus grandes donc
je pense qu'il faut vraiment que nous
n'en restions pas opposition de principe
mais bien que nous ayons des traductions
en termees juridique qui matérialiseront
cet engagement je le dis parce que sans
doute chacun il voit peut-être les
limites et les freins que cela peut
consacrer sur certains territoires mais
c'est nécessaire de faire ce pas même si
bien sûr je réserve la discussion sur
des adaptations peut-être nécessaires je
pense en particulier au territoire de
montagne même si le principe n'est pas
de trouver des dérogations à toutes les
dispositions mais bien de vérifier
évidemment dès aujourd'hui que nous
n'aboutirons pas à des contradictions
sur certains territoires spécifiques
monsieur viran vous avez aussi eu parler
de l'articulation nécessaire entre les
EPF d'État et les EPFL là aussi il y a
eu des inquiétudes je veux les lever il
est évident que nous voulons une bonne
articulation entre les deux vous avez
parfaitement euh parfaitement dit les
choses les EPFL et si carence les EPF et
notamment pour éventuellement aussi des
projets d'une plus grande ampleur ou la
nécessité d'un d'un outil d'État s'opère
mais il y a pas d'opposition de ma part
entre les deux il y a bien une
complémentarité dans les modes
d'intervention entre les établissements
publics fonciers d'État et les
établissements publics fonciers locaux
sur la préhemption sur les
lescopropriétés dégradé vous avez raison
nous avançons là aussi dans le cadre de
travaux parlementaires issus il faut le
dire et là je je tiens à à les saluer
aussi des remontées et des propositions
d'élus locaux confrontés jour après jour
à ces situations et qui ont nourri la
réflexion parlementaire de cas concrets
et de la nécessité d'y apporter des
réponses monsieur Calvet a
évoqué euh un sujet que que je qui me
tient beaucoup à cœur c'est de dire vous
faites une loi pour les Parisiens alors
que dans tout un tas de territoirees de
France il y en a pas besoin mais alors
moi je vais vous dire Monsieur Calvet si
on encadre vous avez je crois je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit vous parle du prix
du pain le prix des escargots et qu'on
dit que les six escargots sont encadrés
et que leur prix de vente ne peut pas
dépasser 50 €. ça ne posera de problème
à personne c'est-à-dire que quand il n'y
a pas de problème de tension comandbien
même il y aurait un encadrement celui-ci
ne pose aucun problème à personne donc
ça ne pose de problème ça n'a vocation
que de répondre aux situations qui
nécessite un encadrement mais c'est très
très logique il se trouve que parmi les
les nombreuses critique mais j'y
reviendrai je vous vois aussi les
sourcils monsieur le sénateur d'allier
je reviendrai sur le j'ai adoré votre
phrase sur le marché contre le marché si
le marché ne marche pas chers amis
utilisons le marché contre le marché
alors effectivement c'est un argument
imparable parce qu'on pourra si jamais
le marché contre le marché ne fonctionne
pas envisager de recourir au marché
contre le marché qui était contre le
marché et à ce compte-là je peux vous
dire ça peut durer très très
longemp donc je veux dire que ces
dispositions ont vocation à s'appliquer
aux endroits où ils sont utiles de la
même manière que l'argument qui consiste
à dire vous vous attaquez aux
conséquences et non pas aux causes est
totalement réversible nous nous
attaquons et aux causes et aux
conséquences j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dire que quand un malade est malade on
peut à la fois lui donner des
antibiotiques pour s'attaquer à ses
microbes et donner du doliprane ou de du
paracétamol pour soigner la fièvre ce
que nous devons faire auj aujourd'hui
c'est soigner la fièvre ce qui nous
interdit pas et au contraire puisque
nous l'avons déjà fait comme vous avez
été plusieurs à souligner nous sommes au
3è étage de la fusée nous avons déjà mis
en place un certain nombre de mesures
pour faciliter la transformation de
locaux de bureau en logement pour
favoriser la densification pour
favoriser les pour abandonner pour
mettre fin au recours abusifs et mafieux
contre les permis de construire donc
nous nous attaquons aux causes mais
aussi aux conséquences monsieur le
sénateur CALV je pense que ça n'est pas
incompatible et c'est une erreur de
croire que l'un suffit à répondre à
l'autre enfin sur la question de posé
par monsieur Dubois sur le corset versus
l'oxygène de la même manière il est
absolument à mon avis erroné de
considérer qu'on ne peut pas à la fois
essayer de libérer du foncier public de
favoriser dans les zones tendues l'accès
au fonciers et la rapidité de la
construction c'est le sens de
l'ordonnance sur les projets intégrés
pour le logement qui permettront d'aller
plus vite sur les opérations de logement
en zone tendue mais aussi de contenir
les loyers quand ils ont explosé alors
même que les revenus n'ont pas suivi
quand les loyers à la relocation ont
augmenté de 40 % en disant c'est
simplement incompatible de manière
structurelle avec les revenus d'une
grande partie des familles et je le dis
parce que nous avons eu de nombreuses
heures de discussions avec les uns ou
avec les autres je sais que tous et
toutes vous avez été confrontés à la
situation de famille de jeunes qui
étaiit face à un mur celui de l'accès au
logement qui leur était rendu de plus en
plus difficile chacun connaît des
situations jour après jour et la
situation s'aggrave donc nous devons
intervenir et oui je crois qu'il est de
la responsabilité de la puissance
publique de réguler un marché quand
celui-ci ne fonctionne pas et c'est le
cas du marché du logement et si la
question de la réponse par
l'augmentation des du montant des loyers
qui aurait donc abouti j'allais dire de
manière ass c'est naturel à
l'augmentation de la construction devait
fonctionner depuis 30 ans nous nous en
serions rendus compte la l'agravation de
la crise a elle-même engendré
l'aggravation de la crise c'est-à-dire
que l'augmentation du coût de
l'immobilier a rendu aussi très
difficile l'accès à une clientèle
solevable simplement pour l'acquisition
maintenant des gens dans un logement
locatif alors même qu'il aur qu'ils
auraient voulu accéder à la propriété
donc nous sommes dans une situation
bloquée et l'ensemble des acteurs en
sont conscients l'objectif c'est donc de
faire baisser la fièvre de rendre le
logement access cible pour le plus grand
nombre en contenant l'évolution des
loyers et vous l'avez dit Madame chorch
il ne s'agit pas d'un blocage en le
regrettant il s'agit pas d'un blocage ou
d'une baisse de l'ensemble des loyers je
pense qu'à ce stade nous devons et c'est
déjà un grand changement aller vers
cette évolution qui est celle de la
régulation avec une contention une
contention de l'augmentation pas un
blocage une contention de l'évolution
mais l'instauration de cet encadrement
dans les zones où les loyers ont si
fortement augmenté ces dernières années
aboutira à entre 25 et 30 % des loyers
qui devront effectivement à la
relocation ou au renouvellement du bail
baisser donc cela aboutira à faire
baisser les loyers qui ont fortement
dérapé ces dernières années et à
contenir durablement l'évolution
puisqu'il est prévu que le décret
d'encadrement au renouvellement de bail
ou à la relocation soit maintenu
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y ait pas
d'augmentation possible au-delà de l'IRL
entre deux loyers je voudrais revenir
sur un point qui a été évoqué par
quelques-uns en disant avec
l'encadrement des loyers on va euh
pousser à l'augmentation des loyers
alors là c'est aussi un argument la
première fois que on m'a apporté cet
argument j'avoue que je suis restée un
peu sans voix parce que comment on peut
imaginer que les loyers vont davantage
augmenter dans un système encadré que
dans un système totalement libre comme
celui que nous connaissons ça ça c'est
totalement inopérant donc je veux le
redire une nouvelle fois évidemment non
d'abord une grande partie des loyers
vont diminuer et parallèlement les
nouveaux loyers seront dans ce système
de contention qui n'empêchera pas qui ne
bloquera ser pas les prix avec les
effets pervers qu'on a pu connaître dans
le passé mais qui contiendra leur
évolution de manière extrêmement forte
avec une bien plus grande corrélation
avec l'augmentation des revenus des
ménages qu'ils ont vocation à accueillir
vous avez néanmoins dit Madame chorge
que vous saluiez le le volontarisme on
peut faire beaucoup de reproches à la
loi allure on ne peut pas lui reprocher
de ne pas justement faire preuve d'un
réel volontarisme d'un réel volontarisme
qui a pesé un équilibre ce qui
d'ailleurs conduit à ce que les critique
sur cette loi puisse ont pu provenir de
toutes parts mais nous avons fait un
choix qui est un choix délicat un choix
qui est un choix compliqué qui est celui
de tenir une ligne de crête une ligne
d'équilibre qui n'opte pas pour un camp
ou pour un autre si tentez qu'on puisse
parler de camp ce qui est une position
sans doute inconfortable mais qui me
paraît à moyen terme être la position la
plus durable et la plus efficace et
c'est cet équilibre que j'aurais
l'honneur de défendre devant vous
amendement après amendement cet
équilibre entre propriétaire et
locataire cet équilibre entre régulation
et évolution et cet équilibre en matière
d'urbanisme entre simplification
efficacité des outils et évidemment
respect des élus locaux monsieur mard a
parlé et avec raison du fait que une loi
ne suffisait pas et il est absolument
certain que je ne peux ici et je ne vais
ici pas prétendre que cette loi à elle
seule résoudra la crise du logement que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui cette loi
est la 3oème étape d'un travail
législatif avec des mesures d'urgence
dans un premier temps mais elle
s'accompagne et elle continuera de
s'accompagner d'une mobilisation de tous
les acteurs en faveur de la construction
je je crois et marieë linman n'est pas
là à cet instant mais mais j'en ai
souris avec mon prédécesseur benoî
apparu la querelle des chiffres est une
querelle veain pour la bonne et simple
raison que les mises en chantier d'une
année sont en général le résultat des
dépôts de permis de construire d'un
ministre précédent qui eux-même étaient
le résultat d'une politique menée 3 ans
auparavant souvent par un ministre
précédent et que les résultats effectifs
de la politique du logement que mène ce
gouvernement et que j'ai l'honneur de
défendre devant vous peut-être et sans
doute qu'ils seront présentés et je
l'espère avec succès par un de ou une de
mes successeurs c'est la règle en
matière de logement c'est la règle dans
ce ministère qui est un ministère
essentiel parce qu'il touche vous avez
été plusieurs à le rappeler un sujet
absolument fondamental pour la vie de
nos concitoyens mais il est évident
qu'il faut prendre des décisions qui
sont des décisions structurelles qui
sont des décisions qui remettent le
marché du logement dans des règles et
dans un mode de fonctionnement beaucoup
plus simple et je voudrais répondre à
Monsieur mard qui parlait de
simplification que la création des
documents types tels que le BA type ou
l'état des liotypes sont des outils de
simplification et pas de complexité
aujourd'hui il y a des beau avec des
clauses abusifs qui donneent lieu à des
contentieux avoir un document type sur
lequel tout le monde propriétaire comme
lo locataire pourra se baser est un
outil de simplification et notamment de
simplification administrative je
répondrai à à cet instant aussi sur un
certain nombre de points sur laagulle en
vous disant que je répondrai pas sur
l'ensemble des éléments puisque je pense
que nous aurons l'occasion je parle sous
le contrôle de monsieur le Président
d'avoir un certain nombre de de débats
autour de autour de laagulle elle ne
mérite honnêtement ni excès d'honneur ni
excès d'indignité c'est un dispositif
qui l' aussi est le résultat d'une lente
pinturation qui est le résultat du
travail initié par Marie Noë linman avec
la couverture universelle logement qui
est une première étape qui a été faite
avec le locapace une deuxième étape avec
la GRL et la volonté d'aller vers une
plus grande généralisation par
Jean-Louis borlot c'est une réflexion
commune et qui avance et qui avec ses
dispositions va franchir un nouveau cap
mais avec votre permission je répondrai
sur l'ensemble des éléments très précis
notamment sur les
moyens de lever toutes les euh
amplifications qu'on a pu entendre j'ai
entendu évoquer des milliers de
fonctionnaires euh ou bien le fait qu'il
y aurait des des taux d'IMP payer
considérable puisque les gens
considéraient qu'ils sont euh couverts
et que donc ils peuvent ne plus payer
leur loyer toutes ces choses un peu
fantasques mais il est normal de pouvoir
lever les interrogations et je m'y
emploierai dans le cadre du débat
monsieur maçon a évoqué la position de
l'Association des mares ruraux de France
je crois que certains euh sénateurs et
sénatrices ont déjà répondu mais là
aussi j'ai souhaité après avoir entendu
les expressions et vu les signatures
collectées par cette association
rencontrer son président avec lequel
nous avons une discussion extrêmement
franche et je je tiens à dire que lui
aussi et ça a été évoqué et
l'Association des maires rurau de France
soutient la position de compromis
trouvée au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques et que je n'ai qu'à
me féliciter de ce travail collaboratif
et que dans ce cadre-là aussi je
souhaite que cette position soit soit
maintenue madame linman longuement
évoqué la question de la régulation et
vous avez tout à l'heure aussi expliqué
que on avait pu artificiellement doper
si je puis dire la construction avec des
mesures notamment très coûteuses mais
qui étaient aussi très courttermistes et
qui ont eu des effets secondaires nous
avons choisi de mettre fin à ces
dispositions qui pouvaient donner le
sentiment que les choses allaient mieux
mais de manière très temporaire comme un
feu de paille pour nous attaquer à des
réformes de structure et aussi à des
dispositifs plus équilibré c'est un
choix politique vous avez dit et vous
l'avez défendu parfaitement madame
linman et efftivement c'est le choix du
gouvernement je vous ai répondu monsieur
laabé sur les l'interpénétration entre
le travail sur la loi d'orientation
agricole et les mesures que nous
portions je voudrais dire à Madame Lamur
que un certain nombre de ces remarques
sont des remarques qui sont des
remarques de forme et un certain nombre
sont des remarques de fond et il est
vrai que nous pouvons et moi ça ne me
choque pas c'est le sens aussi du débat
politique avoir des désaccords on peut
considérer qu'on ne souhaite pas que on
s'attaque à la régulation de certains
marchés et considérer par principe qu'on
est opposé à l'encadrement des loyers je
je ne critique pas cette position je dis
que nous avons fait un choix différent
que c'est le choix du gouvernement c'est
l'engagement du président Hollande et
que nous tiendrons à cette position même
si je peux concevoir que d'autres
pensent différemment madame lettard a
avancé sur la présentation d'un autre
système de garantie universelle qui se
baserait sur une assurance obligatoire
là aussi je reviendrai dans le débat
c'est une proposition qui a été avancée
dont donccun ont déjà et on le voit avec
la GRL constater les limites et
j'expliquerai pourquoi cette piste a été
évoquée par le gouvernement et
abandonnée pour tout un tas de raisons
que je présenterai de manière un peu
plus détaillé quand nous aborderons
l'article consacré à la gulle monsieur
Mirassou vous faites partie et je vous
en remercie de ceux qui ont travaillé
sur cette question relative au au plui
de manière constructive et et je n'ai
vraiment je le redis qu'à qu'à me
féliciter et qu'à vous remercier les uns
et les autres d'avoir aussi fait
confiance à la ministre ce qui n'est pas
toujours toujours facile quand on est
quand on est parlementaire sur la
volonté que j'avais et qu'à le
gouvernement d'aboutir à une position
qui soit une position partager sur ce
sujet monsieur Colomba a évoqué le club
chic du club plui alors je voudrais lui
dire que le le club plu rassemble des
élus et en particulier et de manière
très importante des élus de communauté
de communes rurales qui s'appuie sur un
travail en commun pour être doté d'une
meilleure ingénierie c'est tout le sens
de ce club qui n'est pas un club mais
qui est la volonté de travaill en commun
et j'invite tous celles et tous ceux
d'ailleurs qui sont intéressés à pouvoir
y participer il est très très ouvert
mais j'en profite pour indiquer que
conscient des nécessités des besoins en
ingénierie
que provoqueront la mise en œuvre des
pli dans un certain nombre
d'intercommunalités qui donc décideront
de mettre en en application cette
disposition l'état s'organisera pour
pouvoir avoir un appui à ces
collectivités locales et notamment aux
collectivités rurales qui aujourd'hui ne
disposent pas de l'ingénierie qui comme
je l'ai indiqué tout à l'heure sont pour
l'essentiel d'entrraelle sans document
d'urbanisme décidé par ces collectivités
locales je voudrais là aussi répondre à
un sujet qui a été évoqué par
quelques-uns d'entre vous sur la
question de l'habitat léger et
démontable je sais que c'est un des
sujets qui peut être le plus facilement
caricaturé euh voire folklorisé je pense
que ça ne le M pas et que si nous avons
travaillé sur cejet sur ce sujet c'est
notamment pour sortir de l'insécurité
juridique et d'un conflit de
jurisprudence qui sur certains
territoires reconnaissent ses habitats
comme des tentes et donc comme pouvant
être installés sur le territoire de ces
communes et dans d'autres cas les
déclarent illégal au motif qu'elle ne
dispose pas de permis de construire
mettant donc les élus face à une
difficulté très grande et a des
situations de conflit qui sont parfois
des situations de conflit qui durent
pendant des années l'objectif du projet
de lo loi et donc d'apporter une réponse
juridique aux élus pour sortir de
l'instabilité mais aussi reconnaître que
les dispositions d'urbanisme doivent
prendre en compte l'ensemble des modes
d'habitat qu'on le veuille ou qu'on le
veuille pas et même si c'est très
marginal et que chacun convient que ça a
sans doute vocation à le rester ce mode
d'habitat est respectable et que nous
devons donner aux élus la possibilité de
faire en sorte que ces modes d'habitat
se passent et s'installe dans de bonnes
conditions je le redis le projet de loi
ne prévoit cette installation que sur
les terrains constructibles ou sur les
zones pastillées dans le cadre des
documents d'urbanisme par les élus c'est
une clarification juridique de ces types
d'installation d'habitat permanen
démontaable je dis bien permanent
puisqu'il ne s'agit évidemment pas là de
l'habitat
touristique monsieur le noir vous avez
et je vous ai répondu évoqué un certain
nombre de sujets sur à la fois les
chiffres de la construction et sur
laagul sur la Gul je le redis je
répondrai à l'ensemble des questions
point par point de manière très précise
al à l'occasion de l'examen de cet
article monsieur cardraon a salué et
souligné le fait que le siiao devienne
le pilote en matière d'hébergement et
d'accès au logement c'est effectivement
un des éléments qui était ressorti du
travail lors de la conférence de lutte
contre la pauvreté et pour l'inclusion
sociale monsieur Dalier j'ai légèrement
ironisé sur votre marché contre le
marché parce que je crois que et
peut-être que ce système d'encadrement
des loyers ne durera pas pendant 30 ans
mais en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que nous en avons besoin nous ne
pouvons pas rester sans rien faire et
qu'aujourd'hui la réponse par le marché
est une réponse qui ne suffit pas et
qu'il faut donc additionner les deux
sujets la construction la relance de
projets de construction la
transformation notamment dans les zones
tendues de locaux de bureau en en lieu
de en logement et c'est possible et
l'ordonnance qui a été publiée il y a 15
jours permet de rendre beaucoup plus
facile pour les élus ces transformations
donc nous avons doté et et déjà décidé
tous les outils qui permettent
l'accélération de la construction mais
nous devons avoir cette loi de structure
qui s'attaque à une situation qui est
devenue intolérable monsieur Donis vous
avez évoqué la question comme d'autres
des chartes de parc c'est un sujet qui
est un sujet à la fois très technique
mais aussi très politique et tout à fait
important nous y consacrerons le temps
nécessaire l'idée est bien de ne pas
complexifier les strates juridiques
entre notamment les Scott et les
charartes de parc mais de bien
reconnaître aussi la démarche
extrêmement volontaire et extrêmement
engagé de tous les élus qui sont engagés
dans les parcs naturels
régionaux monsieur
grosidier a fait une intervention dont
l'essentiel que j'ai retenu et qu'il
fallait me qualifier de bourreau je
tiens à lui préciser que comme pour mon
titre de ministre je préfère tant qu'à
faire qui m'appelle madame la bourau ce
sera plus clair pour tout le monde quant
à Monsieur des plans vous avez raison la
question de la situation des outrères en
matière de logement est très compliqué
je tiens à vous dire que nous
travaillons main dans la main avec mon
collègue Victor Lurel sur ces questions
que c'est dans ce cadre que nous avons
remis à niveau la ligne budgétaire
unique dans le PLF 2013 mais également
dans le PLF 2014 que nous avons maintenu
la défiscalisation pour la construction
de logement social et que notamment les
dispositions sur le logement indigne
auront une application qui j'espère sera
très utile pour les élus locaux
particulièrement concernés par ce type
de problème dans un certain nombre de
territoires et de villes outremer madame
Bouret vous avez évoqué la question des
zones de montagne j'y ai déjà répondu
mais un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur et ça n'est pas
la première fois que je le dis ici
devant les sénateurs qui est les
question des cœurs de Bour nous
travaillons à des modalité
d'intervention qui appuieront les élus
locaux pour la rénovation des
centesbours où le vieillissement du parc
crée et peut provoquer de la nécrose
avec des constructions à l'extérieur
mais avec le départ des commerces mais
aussi des habitants avec toutes les
conséquence que ça en matière de de vie
des villages et des bourgs donc nous
travaillons pour des réponses pour une
réponse opérationnelle je vais prendre
un parallèle qui est un parallèle un peu
particulier mais de la même manière que
nous avons travaillé avec la création de
l'agence nationale rénovation urbaine
sur les grands quartiers dégradé pour
lequel il fallait une intervention
concertée je il me semble qu'il nous
faut trouver des réponses qui seront des
réponses d'appui pour ces problématiques
de Centre Bourse sur lesquels le sujet
est actuellement en en travail au sein
du min ministère madame niikou vous avez
vous aussi parlé des spécificités
locales des zones de montagne je le dis
nous traiterons cette question en étant
aussi vigilant sur le fait que les
spécificités et l'ouverture de certains
dispositifs n'ai pas des effets à
rebours donc nous travaillerons
précisément sur les amendements qui ont
été déposés évidemment monsieur Bourquin
j'avais remercié vos remerciements
puisqu'ils sont vraiment très partagé je
voudrais terminer en disant toute ma
reconnaissance au président Raoul je je
crois que l'état d'esprit dans lequel ce
projet de loi et la discussion s'aborde
lui doit énormément que cé en commission
des affaires économiques et et par
l'adoption d'amendement qu'un certain
nombre de sujets très compliqués ont été
ont été déliés et moi qui n'est pas
connu le travail parlementaire avant la
réforme qui a donné ce poids aux
commissions je ne peux que constater
comment les choses fonctionnent et je
peux vous dire que je trouve extrêmement
agréable ce travail partagé entre les
parlementaires et notamment le travail
que vous avez mené au sein de votre
commission monsieur le Président que je
suis donc très heureuse que nous allions
au fond du débat et que dans quelques
heures je crois ou quelques dizaines
d'heures nous puissions aller au bout de
la loi je vous remercie mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
merci Madame la
Ministre la discussion générale est
close et nous allons donc passer à la
discussion du texte de la commission et
sur l'article 1er j'ai une demande de
parole de Madame church
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues en abordant
maintenant dans la discussion des
dispositions de ce projet de loi et
notamment sur ce titre dont l'objectif
est de favoriser l'accès de tous à un
logement digne et
abordable je voulais revenir sur
quelques éléments liminires d'abord nous
satisfaire d'avoir en face de nous une
ministre qui ne considère pas que le
logement est un bien comme les autres
soumis à marchandisation et spéculation
un certain nombre de mesures de ce
projet de loi en témoigent par ailleurs
cependant forcé de reconnaître que nous
partons de loin les 10 années de droite
ont marqué profondément le
paysage trop longtemps l'investissement
dans la pierre a été massivement reporté
sur les acteurs privés qu'il s'agisse
des professionnels ou de simples
particulierers c'est ce que nous avons
appelé l'externalisation du financement
de la politique du logement on nous a
vendu à l'époque l'idée d'une France des
propriétaires le ministre de l'époque
estimant que le fait d'être propriétaire
constituer la meilleure garantie pour se
constituer une retraite le logement est
ainsi devenu vecteur de revenus
intéressant voire complémentaire pour
ceux qui avaient choisi d'investir dans
la pierre et ceux qui le pouvaient choix
intéressant au profit d'exonération
fiscale multiple pesant le double des
crédits budgétaires octroyés à la
politique du
logement les conditions sociales et
économiques se dégradant et
parallèlement la demande de logement
augmentant les investisseurs ont
considéré que la tension du marché était
une auè permettant alors de faire
exploser les loyers tout cela a conduit
ce que la part des dépenses en matière
de logement dans le budget nos
concitoyens pèse de manière anormalement
élevée ce loger est devenu un défi pour
un grand nombre d'entre eux aujourd'hui
sécuriser les locataires c'est à notre
avis augmenter les APL et ne pas les les
geler comme le prévoit la prochaine loi
de finance sécuriser les locataires
comme les bailleurs c'est mener une
politique de l'emploi qui élève les
garanties sociales collectives
permettent notamment un rehaussement du
SMIC et des bas salaires sécurisé c'est
également et nous en parlerons la
semaine prochaine ne pas porter atteinte
au niveau des pensions par la réforme
des retraites sécuriser ce n'est pas
rendre nouvellement imposable des
familles lourdement touchées par la
crise et qui se battent pour continuer
de vivre dignement ce gouvernement doit
choisir sa ligne politique mener une
politique de l'austérité va accroître
les difficultés de nos concitoyens et
notamment leur accès au logement d'autre
part eu égard à la faiblesse des aides à
la construction et la baisse programmée
des dotations aux collectivités dans le
casadre des lois de finances comment
croire alors que les élus pourront
remplir leurs obligations en terme de
construction à l'ône de ces débats il
nous semblait important de replacer ce
projet de loi dans le contexte plus
global à défaut de changement de ligne
politique qui enferme notre pays dans le
déclin et malgré les intentions
généreuses portées par ce texte le droit
au logement risque de rester un vœux
pieux ce que nous ne voulons pas
malheureusement trop difficile à
atteindre pour un trop grand nombre de
nos concitoyens je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Claude
Lenoir merci monsieur le Président
Madame le Ministre
madame la ministre je crois que pour
aborder ce débat dans les meilleures
conditions il faut éviter tous les
malentendus et vous m'avez répliqué que
j'aurais cité des chiffres qui n'étaient
pas convaincant dans la mesure où vous
auriez compris que je parlais de
construction réalisé évidemment les
constructions demandent un certain temps
et les efforts des uns se répercutent
sur 2 ans 3 ans plus tard c'est pas ce
que j'ai dit j'ai cité des chiffres des
financement voté par les lois de
finances chaque année alors pour vous
convaincre
complètement je parle évidemment des des
logements
sociaux pour vous convaincre
complètement je vais prendre un tableau
qui vient de votre ministère ministère
de l'Égalité des territoires et du
logement et le montant des financements
qui ont été
voté sous le gouvernement Jospin et
ensuite sont les suivants
en l'an 2000 40000 en l'an 2001
57000 un peu moins en 2002 et c'est en
2003 qu'on commence à voir les
financements augmentés 60000 en 2003
70000 en 2004 on arrive des 2006 à
100000 pendant plusieurs années ça
augmente à 120000 en 2009 ça atteint
131509 chiffres historiques en 2010
voilà madame les ministres les chiffres
non pas des logements construits mais
des financements pour logements sociaux
démonstration est faite que sous le
gouvernement Jospin l'effort a été
insuffisant et que ce sont les
gouvernements qui ont suivi qui ont fait
l'effort nécessaire pour redresser une
situation qui nous
alarmé merci chers collègues la parole
est à Madame
lineman euh
noir
oublie le que notre collègue le noir
n'est pas assez précis dans ces
chiffres premièrement il s'agit bien des
chiffres financés mais l'inscription
budgétaire ce n'est pas les logements
financés les logements financés ce sont
les dossiers déposés par les organismes
or il se trouve que pendant tout le
gouvernement Jose pas attendez ben je
connais bien ces chiffres sont vrais
pour les chiffres financés mais sous le
gouvernement Jospin la ligne budgétaire
qui était votée n'était pas entièrement
consommée et donc les 30 secondes 30
secondes donc du point de vue budgétaire
les gouvernements avaient fait beaucoup
plus en aide à la pierre pour autant il
n'était pas utilisé par les organismes à
l'époque et il y a une remontée car un
plan de relance a été fait fin 2000
début 2001 et ce plan de relance a
commencé à faire ses effets en 2001 2002
2003 pour autant mon cher collègue pour
autant sur ces chiffres d'abord je vous
rappelle qu'à l'époque n'était pas
compté dans les logements sociaux les
foyers d'hébergement les foyers et par
exemple quand vous avez un un organisme
qui est une résidence étudiante
aujourd'hui il est compté dans cela à
l'époque tel n'était pas le cas
deuxièmement à l'époque les pls
n'étaient qu'émergents puisqu'ils n'ont
été créés que fin 2000 et que vous vous
il ne vous aura pas échapper que
l'augmentation de vos chiffres entre les
le 2001 et 2000 procède essentiellement
d'une montée en puissance des pls que
notre gouvernement a créé et qui est
évidemment son monté à puissance ensuite
et pour colore le débat je vous dirai
que la meilleure méthode c'est de
regarder très clairement combien il y
avait d'HLM quand nous avons quitté le
gouvernement et combien il y en a
aujourd'hui il y avait 4 millions de
logement HLM en 2001 fin 2001 il y a
aujourd'hui
4400000 HLM ça veut dire qu'en 10 ans
vous avez fait 400000 HLM de plus en
France ce qui fait une moyenne de 40000
et pourquoi parce qu'il ne suffit pas
d'avoir des dossiers déposés pour qu'il
y ait des permis de construire et des
dossiers réalisés un HLM peut avoir fait
l'objet de trois mesures de financement
deuxièmement parce que vous avez vendu
du parc HLM massivement et troisièmement
parce que vous avez démoli avec l'enrue
ce qui était une bonne chose mais ne
calculez pas les démolitions et les
reconstructions comme du logement neuf
comme vous le faites donc en réalité
hélas quels que soient les gouvernements
car je plaide de coupable je l'ai
toujours dit nous n'avons pas fait assez
sous le gouvernement Jospin pour la
construction de logement de logements
sociaux en particulier mais ne vous
mettez pas en situation de faire croire
que vous avez contribué à améliorer la
situation alors que vous l'avez
détérioré merci chers collèg
alors nous avons quatre amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 88 est présenté par
Monsieur van dirondong au nom de la
commission des lois oui madame la
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement supprime la définition de la
résidence principale en raison de
difficultés pratique de mise en œuvre en
application de la définition proposée la
qualification deés ridence principale
est fondé exclusivement sur la durée
d'occupation du local c'est-à-dire 8
mois sur une année qu'adiendra-t-il en
cas de litige au cours de la première
année du bail si la durée de 8 mois
n'est pas expirée le juge ne sera pas en
mesure d'apprécier le caractère
principal de la résidence certes on me
fait observer que cette durée de 8 mois
est déjà prévu dans certains textes mais
il s'agit de dispositions de nature
réglementaire d'autres
critères sont également prévus par ces
textes réglementaires je prends par
exemple l'article
r6411 du Code de la Construction qui
fait référence à une occupation
effective et continue du local dès lors
la commission de loi estime que cette
définition n'a pas vocation à figurer
dans la loi elle estime que le critère
choisi est trop restrictif et qu'il faut
laisser au juges toute l'attitude pour
apprécier le caractère principal de la
résidence merci chers collègu
l'amendement 418 rectifié présenté par
Monsieur Frassa merci monsieur le
Président si vous me permettez je vais
défendre également le 419 qui suit cet
amendement vise à ce que le critère
d'une occupation du logement pendant au
moins 8 mois par an ne soit pas
opposable au français s'étant expatrié
pour une raison professionnelle
détachement à l'étranger à la demande
d'un employeur français mais aussi choix
d'une activité professionnelle à
l'étranger y compris en contrat local ou
poursivre leur conjoint C amendement
s'il était adopté les dispenseraiit
ainsi des formalités de changement
d'usage onéreuses et susceptibles d'être
bloqué par les copropriétaires et ce
d'autant plus qu'un Français qui vit à
l'étranger ne pourra défendre sa cause
lors des réunions de compropriété il est
important que les expatriés puissent
conserver leur habitation en France non
seulement pour l'utiliser lors de leur
retour périodique mais surtout en
prévision de leur réinstallation
définitive la loocation de courte durée
constitue le seul moyen de répondre à
ses besoins de disponibilité sans
condamner le bien a rester vacant
pendant de longues périodes la
formulation actuelle qui met l'accent
sur les obligations professionnelles
permet une interprétation restrictive
limitant au seuls salariés contraints
par leur entreprise à une mobilité
professionnelle à l'étranger le bénéfice
de voir leur habitation en France
assimilé à une résidance principale une
assimilation de l'habitation en France
des expatriés à leur résidence
principale a déjà été prévu à l'article
158 du code général des impôts il serait
donc juste que les salariés en contrat
local à l'étranger les entrepreneurs
ayant créé une activité hors de France
où encore les conjoints d'expatriés
puissent également en
bénéficier le suivant monsieur le
Président est un amendement de repli euh
par rapport au 418 que je viens
d'exposer et qui vise à assouplir la
formulation trop restrictive du mot
obligation un Français qui choisit de
partir à l'étranger faute de perspective
professionnelle en France le fait pour
raison professionnelle et non par
obligation imposée par un employeur il
ne serait donc pas juste que seuls les
salariés détachés par leur entreprise
bénéficient de l'assimilation de leur
habitation en France à une résidence
principale et donc de l'exonération de
changement d'usage en cas de location de
courte durée je vous remercie merci
chers collègu l'amendement 560 rectifié
présenté par Monsieur
mzzard Merci monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement qui a déjà été présenté à
l'Assemblée
nationale par le député Joël girud qui
est le président de la commission
permanente du conseil national de la
montagne vise à prendre en compte les
besoins des
saisonniers selon l'alinéa 10 de
l'article 1er du présent projet de loi
les dispositions de la loi 1989 ne
s'appliquent pas au logement attribué ou
loué en raison de l'exercice d'une
fonction ou de l'occupation d'un emploi
et au location consenti aux travailleurs
saisonniers à l'exception des
disposition concernant le dossier de
diagnosticque technique et la dcence du
logement j'entends que les besoins des
saisonniers sont différents de ceux des
locataires classiques dans la mesure où
il louent des logements meublés pour des
durées courtes variant en fonction de la
durée de leur contrat de travail et des
saisons et à cet égard on pourrait
considérer que l'extension de toute la
loi de 89 n'est pas opportune mais est
àdire que les dispositions visant le
niveau des loyers le dépôt de garantie
ou bien encore l'agulle le bénéfice des
aides personnelles les charges locatives
ne sont pas applicables aux location
consenti aux travailleurs saisonniers
donc l'objet de cet amendement est
surtout de vous Inter appeler Madame la
Ministre car depuis des
décennies cette question du logement des
travailleurs qui viennent faire la
saison dans les hôtels les restaurants
les remontées mécaniques en zone de
montagne ou sur la côte est un véritable
casse-tête dans les villes touristiques
ou les stations du littoral ou de
montagne et les règles en matière de
bail ne sont pas adaptées à cette
catégorie les locations sont en saison
al leors prix le plus haut et de toute
manière la précarisation
où l'image de mauvais payeurs de ces
travailleurs fait fuir les bailleurs
bien souvent ces saisonniers en sont
réduits à un système D sur lequel tout
le monde ferme les yeux depuis des
décennies d'autre part l'alinéa 5
précise que la résidence principale est
entendue comme le logement occupé au
moins 8 mois sauf obligation
professionnelle ces derniers termes
couvrent-il la mobilité professionnelle
des travailleurs saisonniers consécutive
à la nécessité d'exercer leur emplo sur
des lieux géographiques différents selon
les saisons les besoins du marché les
offres d'emploi ou leurs compétences si
ce n'était le cas les accords
interprofessionnels pour le logement des
saisonniers signés en Savoie dans les
Hautes Alpes ou Alpes de hauteprence
n'auraient plus lieu d'être car il
mobilise des Fonds d'Action Logement
alors que l'encadrement de ses emplois
les réserves au financement des
résidences principales enfin lorsque les
travailleurs saisonniers disposent d'un
logement ou pied à terre fixe ils
doivent pouvoir le LOU lou pour de
courtes durée pendant leur absence sans
avoir à demander une autorisation
préalable ou un changement
d'usage merci chers collègu monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues sur
l'amendement de Monsieur van deron qui
la commission des lois la Commission est
un peu gênée parce qu'elle considère que
les 8 mois consid sont une avancée
effectivement comme l'a dit le le
rapporteur et figure des dans des textes
réglementaires du CCH donc c'est pas
quelque chose de de nouveau en ce qui
concerne la difficulté du juge dans la
première année c'est une évidence de
toute façon la première année ça va être
compliqué donc le juge pourra très bien
arbitrer juger sur des critères autres
donc la Commission demande le le retrait
en ce qui concerne les deux amendements
défendus par Monsieur Frassa sur le sur
le premier vous vous demandez à la fois
d'être exonéré des 8 mois pour les les
expatriés mais vous avez dit
professionnels et puis en même temps
d'être exonéré du du du de
l'autorisation de changement d'usage sur
le premier point en ce qui concerne les
les expatriations professionnel il est
bien évident que c'est satisfait c'est
satisfait par le texte de façon assez
claire à notre avis et donc c'est
satisfait aussi pour l' la dérogation à
l'autorisation
de de changement d'usage si ce n'est pas
pour des raisons professionnelles il y a
rien de choquant à ce qu'on demande une
autorisation de changement d'usage je le
dis et je le dis une fois pour toutes
pour que les choses soient claires parce
que dans les ça a été très longtemps
rappelé l'autorisation changement
d'usage ne s'applique que pour les
villes de plus de 200000 habitants et
pour Paris et la petite couronne où
c'est un problème majeur et je pense
qu'il faut pas déroger là-dessus parce
que par que c'est quand même un problème
majeur donc ça ne touche pas les
villages et cetera je je sur l'autre
amendement je ne partage pas votre point
de vue je pense que l'obligation est une
terme claire précis
euh ce que vous proposez peut être sujet
à des interprétations c'est-à-dire que
je peux effectivement partir à
l'étranger pour des raisons
professionnelles ça peut être aussi pour
partir en vacances ça sera très
difficile de de de démontrer que je
cherchais du travail et cetera alors que
obligation professionnelle me paraît
elle mérite aussi effectivement un peu
de subjectivité mais elle me paraît
beaucoup plus claire quant à
l'amendement de de Monsieur mard j'ai
bien compris qu'il s'agissait d'un d'un
amendement d'appel la commission partage
effectivement votre souci de protéger
les travailleurs saisonniers qui sont
comme vous l'avez très bien dit des
facteurs des acteurs importants de de la
vie économique nous pensons aussi que en
ce qui concerne les meublés c'est
satisfait non pas par l'article 1 mais
mais par l'article 4 qui fait rentrer
les meublés dans la loi de 89 si je puis
dire pour pour m'exprimer comme ça et de
toute façon et là aussi ils pourront
bénéficier d'un préavis de 1 mois donc
j'ai bien compris c'était un amendement
d'appel donc je pense que la ministre
complètera mais pour nous c'est
satisfait donc je demande le retrait
pour les quatre amendements monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur favorable
autrement défavorable madame la ministre
quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement je ne vais pas reprendre
les arguments qui ont été avancés par le
rapporteur parce que je les partage je
voudrais simplement indiquer
qu'effectivement à Monsieur virin donc
aujourd'hui la notion de résidence
principale est assez robuste
juridiquement nous ne faisons pas face à
des contentions à des difficultés qui
nécessiteraient de le faire évoluer de
la même manière les motifs qui
permettent le changement d'usage ou qui
permettent le départ pour des
obligations professionnelles sont
aujourd'hui bien encadrés nous ne
faisons pas face à des difficultés sur
ce sujet pour ce qui est des saisonniers
en fait il y a deux de sujets nous avons
déjà longuement parlé de cette question
à l'issue de du dépôt d'un amendement
similaire en fait cet amendement de fait
est satisfait parce qu'aujourd'hui les
questions professionnelles permettent de
lever l'obligation minimale de résidence
donc cette obligation est
intrinsèquement levé mais que le
problème des saisonniers c'est comme
vous l'avez dit dans la présentation de
votre amendement la question de l'accès
au logement davantage que la question de
la résidence principale puisque y
compris les logements meublés comme l'a
dit le rapporteur seront du ressort de
la loi de 1989 et donneront droit à
l'ensemble des dispositions et notamment
à la garantie universelle en revanche
l'accès des saisonniers la capacité
d'avoir un parc mobilisable dans les
périodes de fortes activité notamment
touristique en complément du parc
touristique qui lui est forcément
utilisé pendant C période touristique
est une question à laquelle il nous faut
apporter une réponse et nous travaillons
sur ce sujet en sachant que c'est
effectivement un sujet qui est un sujet
très compliqué et qui pèse aujourd'hui
beaucoup sur les épaules des élus locaux
beaucoup aussi sur sur ce des
professionnels et qui aboutit à à à des
périodes de travail dans des conditions
de logement qui ne sont pas des
conditions acceptables donc je sollicite
comme le comme le rapporteur pour toutes
ces raisons le retrait de ces quatre
amendements en disant que je reste à la
disposition notamment des représentants
euh des parlementaires représentants les
les Français l'étranger si nous avons
loupé des des éléments particuliers ou
si vous avez connaissance de cas
particulierers mais en l'état il nous
semble pas du tout pertinent de changer
euh la loi telle qu'elle est rédigée de
la même manière nous continuons de
travailler sur la question des sers en
disant que pour le cas relatif à la
résidence principale votre amendement
monsieur mzar est satisfait par la
législation actuelle merci Madame la
Ministre alors nous sommes donc sur le
88 est-ce qu'il est retiré monsieur il
n'est pas retiré je n'ai pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuillent bien
lever la
main merci avis contraire
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 418 rectifié n'est pas
retiré non je vous en prie pour
explication de vote je vais peut-être
expliquer j'ai entendu vos arguments
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mais j'ai surtout noté que
vous n'avez employé que le mot raison
professionnelle et donc après m'objecter
que ce sont des obligations
professionnelles alors que dans l'usage
même si juridiquement on sait ce que
veut dire l'obligation professionnelle
vous fermez la porte à tous ceux qui
partent pour créer leur entreprise vous
fermez la porte à tous ceux qui créent
leur entreprise à l'étranger ou à tous
ceux qui ont un contrat local à
l'étranger et vous ne conservez que les
salariés expatriés par leurs entreprises
avec avec ce cette terminologie là donc
moi je maintiens les deux amendements
merci alors sur le 418 rectifié pas de
demande d'explication de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent l'adopter veuillent bien
lever la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre veut
bien lever la main
il n'est pas adopté sur le 419 rectifié
pas de demande d'explication de vote
même vote même vote sur le 560 rectifié
pas de demande d'explication de vote il
n'est pas retiré non que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien lever
la
main merci avis
contraire il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 32 rectifié bis est
présenté par Monsieur tendonné
oui monsieur le Président cet amendement
concerne la rédaction du contrat de
location s s est exigé que le contrat
soit écrit il fait mention au respect
d'un contrat type défini par décret en
Conseil d'État donc il nous semble qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire de remettre en
cause le principe de la liberté
contractuelle du droit français d'autant
plus que la loi définit précisément les
très nombreuses mentions qui doivent
impérativement être précis prisé dans le
bail la rédaction d'un contrat de
location doit être en effet doit
permettre en effet une certaine
souplesse pour s'adapter aux différentes
situations que la loi ne saurait
envisager tout en respectant évidemment
les dispositions
impératives par ailleurs le locataire
est suffisamment protégé par deux
dispositions fondamentales l'article 2
qui indique que les dispositions de la
loi sont d'ordre public de telle sorte
qu'on ne peut y déroger et l'article 4
de la loi qui liste une série de clauses
réputées non écrites
de plus la diversité actuelle dans la
rédaction des beau ne pose pas de
problème puisque la Commission des
clauses abusives exerce un contrôle sur
le le contenu des contrats en publiant
régulièrement des recommandations sur ce
sujet de même il faut noter que la
Commission nationale de concertation
peut parfaitement se saisir du sujet
examiner tous les B en circul en
circulation pour donner un satisfait
site ou demander des modifications comme
l'a fait dans le passé l'ancêtre de la
Commission nationale de concertation la
Commission nationale des rapports
locatifs chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission l'avis est défavorable parce
que la Commission pense que cet
amendement est contraire à à l'idée que
le contratype protège à la fois le le
locataire mais aussi le bailleur donc
c'est un avis défavorable merci Madame
la Ministre quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement la l'avis du Gouvernement
est défavorable parce que contrairement
ce qui est indiqué la mise en place d'un
contratype euh n'est évidemment pas euh
une atteinte à la liberté contractuelle
dans le mesure la mesure où celui-ci n'a
pas vocation à comporter les seules
dispositions contenues à l'article 3 de
la loi du 6 juillet 1989 cette liberté
contractuelle est encadrée de façon à
protéger l'ensemble des parties
notamment la plus faible puisque le
contrat de location devra respecter les
éléments du contratype je tiens à dire
que tant les associations de locataires
qu'un certain nombre de représentants du
monde professionnel disent que
l'existence de ce contratpe sera de
nature à simplifier la vie des uns et
des autres l'avis du Gouvernement est
donc
défavorable donc nous votons sur le 32
rectifier bis pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement ve
bien lever la
main merci avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas validé
358 rectifié la parole est à Monsieur
CALV
bien monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre monsur le rapporteur l'alinéa
14 oblige à mentionner dans le bail le
nom ou la dénomination du bailleur et
son domicile ou son siège social même
lorsque celui-ci a choisi de confier la
gestion de son bien à un mandataire or
les bailleurs qui confient leur bien à
des tiers mandataire désirent le plus
souvent que leur locataire ne
connaissent pas leur adresse personnelle
ou que l'ensemble des demandes de leur
locatair Soi adressé exclusivement à
leur mandataire cet amendement propose
que dans l'hypothèse où le bail indique
le nom ou la dénomination sociale du
mandataire ainsi que son adresse son
siège social les coordonnées du bailleur
ne soi pas
mentionné merci monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission oui
c'est un avis défavorable je comprends
bien les ce que veut dire monsieural
éité au bailleurs d'avoir des
inconvénients mais d'abord c'est un peu
choquant quand même qu'un locataire ne
sache même pas le nom de son
propriétaire et deuxièmement il est tout
à fait important qu'il ait son nom et
son adresse s'il veut envoyer une lettre
recommandée par exemple pour tenter une
une procédure et bien il ne peut pas
passer par son mandataire donc la la la
vie est
défavorable merci Madame la Ministre
l'avis du Gouvernement
oui le le rapporteur a parfaitement
identifié les éléments aucune procédure
ne peut être engagée contre le le
propriétaire je réponds simplement par
par l'absurde si le locataire ne connaît
pas les coordonnées de de son
propriétaire donc avoir comme
interlocuteur un gestionnaire ne peut
absolument pas conduire à lui demander
d'assumer des responsabilités de
propriétaire que par principe il n'a pas
n'étant pas le propriétaire donc l'avis
du Gouvernement est
défavorable
merci alors j'ai des demandes
d'explication de vote oui monsieur
Calvé je sais pas si on mesure bien les
choses dans la réalité d'abord il y a un
contrat de mandat ça fait partie de de
d'un pan de travail d'ailleurs des
agents immobiliers dans notre société et
donc on a souvent les propriétaires
effectivement qui donne en gestion
d'ailleurs qui paye une
rémunération au au au mandataire à
l'administrateur et donc c'est tout à
fait un métier qui est connu depuis très
longtemps et donc sait très bien en
s'adressant à l'administrateur qui est
derrière je je je ne vois pas enfin
j'imagine mal C ces personnes qui vont
qui utilisent les administrateurs pour
gérer leur bien se retrouver tous les
matins au téléphone avec le locataire
qui va leur demander ah ben les viers ne
marche pas la porte ne ferme plus parce
que c'est ce qui va se passer parce que
c'est ça alors que là vous avez un
métier vous confiez votre bien un un
mandataire enfin c'est je je je vois pas
très
bien mais merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui je voudrais juste préciser à
Monsieur CALV que c'est pas une
disposition nouvelle c'est dans le droit
actuel c'est l'article 3 actuellement de
la loi de 89 donc c'est pas
nouveau bien je n'ai pas d'autres
demande d'explication de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veut bien lever la
main merci
opposition l'amendement n'est pas adopté
n en arrivons au 360 rectifiés présenté
par Monsieur Calvé
les les mots la dénomination du
locataire ne sont pas opportuns en effet
la loi ne s'applique qu' locataire
personne physique en conséquence cet
amendement propose de supprimer ces mots
du 2e de l'article 1 du projet de loi
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission
oui c'est un avis défavorable et je fais
remarquer monsieur calvecune personne
morale peut aussi signer un bail donc
c'est absolument nécessaire merci Madame
la Ministre même avis
oui exactement même avis c'est là pour
le coup la formule est nécessaire s'il
s'agit d'une personne morale avis
défavorable merci pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement ve
bien lever la
main merci avis contraire l'amendement
n'est pas adopté l'amendement 159 est
présenté par Mame search
oui merci Monsieur le président donc
l'article 1 modifiant l'article 3 de la
loi 89 a pour objet de préciser les
éléments qui doivent obligatoirement
figurer dans le contrat de location le
texte de l'article 1 prévoit la mention
du loyer médian de référence ainsi que
le loyer médian de référence majorée
pour nous seul le premier doit
apparaître dans le contrat de bail à
titre indicatif sinon à notre avis ce
pourrait être une invitation à porter
son loyer à plus de 20 % sans qu'aucune
justification ne soit donnée demandée au
bailleur du reste s' l' fait mention du
loyer majoré pourquoi ne pas préciser
aussi le montant de loyer minoré nous ne
pensons pas que la référence faite au
loyer médian majoré soit à sa place dans
l'article 1 alors que l'encadrement des
loyers est prévu à l'article 3 de plus
si vous souhaitez informer le locataire
pourquoi ne pas faire mention de cette
majoration possible dans la notice qui
lui sera remise en annexe du bail donc
notre amendement a pour objectif de
préciser donc clarifier les choses à
notre avis ne doit figurer que le loyer
médian merci monsieur le rapporteur quel
est l'avis de la commission
ou c'est un avis défavorable parce que
je crois que le le fait d'indiquer le
loyer médian est aussi une façon pour le
locataire de savoir où il se situe et
éventuellement éventuellement de faire
un recours donc avis défavorable merci
Madame la Ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement
ou oui madame la sénatrice la présence
de ce montant dans le bail et si cela
figure à l'article 1 c'est bien parce
que c'est du ressort du BA type et de
nature a donneré l'information au
locataire là il sera directement sur le
bas où il y a le montant de son loyer il
aura de manière extrêmement visible et à
proximité le montant du loyer maximum
donc je pense que c'est vraiment un
amendement qui est de nature à amputer
le locataire d'une partie de
l'information qui euh est de nature à le
protéger donc je je Seris vraiment
attentive à ce que vous retiriez cet
amendement c'est ma demande parce que je
pense qu'il va dans le sens que vous
souhaitez c'est-à-dire que le locataire
soit pleinement informé euh du fait que
le propriétaire ne peut en aucun cas
dépasser ce montant et que ce cette
information figure directement sur le
bail signé par le locataire lui-même ce
qui sera le meilleur moyen qu' ne soit
pas dissocié et que l'information soit
transparente donc je vous demande le le
retrait de de cet amendement à des fout
j'y serai défavorable mais j'espère vous
avoir convaincu merci madame S il est
retiré
il est retiré très bien l'amendement 78
rectifié bis tombe deux amendements
identiques font l'objet d'une discussion
commune l'amendement 329 rectifié est
présenté par Monsieur
César oui merci monsieur le Président le
projet de loi propose que le loyer
puisse être réduit en fonction de la
surface habitable à l'instar du système
organisé par la loi du 18 décembre 96
dit carè en matière de vente de l'eau de
Co éire qui instore une réduction du
prix en fonction de la superficie or
l'article c'est pour ça que nous
demandons qu'il soit supprimé qui est
envisagé d'introduire dans la loi
modifiée de 6 juillet 89 n'enferme pas
dans un bref délai la
constatation judiciaire pardon par le
locataire de la surface habitable du
logement loué se contentant de faire
produire un effet rétroactif au nouveau
loyer si la demande est introduite dans
les 6 mois de la prise d'effits du bail
la demande est donc à l'état recevable
dans les 3 ans instauré par l'article 71
nouveau courant à compter du jour où le
titulaire d'un droit a connu ou aurait
dû connaître les faits lui permettant
d'exercer ce droit ce qui peut reporter
le délai de contestation bien au-delà
des trois premières années de location
créant ainsi une insécurité juridique
inadmissible sur le montant du loyer il
est donc demandé à l'instar de la loi du
18 décembre 96 d'encadrer la demande à
réduction du loyer dans le délai de 6
mois suivant la prise desffits du
bail chers collègues le 738
rectifiataire présenté par monsieuron il
est il est
défendu
merci monsieur le rapporteur quel est
l'avis de la commission
oui l'avis est défavorable pour les deux
amendements sur la forme la rédaction
pose un problème en effet il ne supprime
pas les dispositions prévoyant les
effets d'une demande intervenant au-delà
de 6 mois ce qui est donc contradictoire
et sur le fond il me semble pas choquant
qu'une telle action puisse être engagée
tout au long du contrat de baille cela
sera une incitation bailleur à prêter
attention à la surface qu'il fait
figurer sur le contrat de location donc
avis défavorable merci Madame la
Ministre quel est l'avis du Gouvernement
oui le rapporteur a expliqué le la
faiblesse de l'amendement sur sur la
forme mais sur le
fond je ne comprends pas pourquoi dès
lors que cette information serait fausse
c'està-dire que la taille du du logement
serait éronné pourquoi au-delà de 6 mois
on ne prendrait plus en considération la
nécessité de corriger alors même que le
texte prévoit que la rétroactivité de la
diminution n'a plus lieu lorsque la
demande intervient après 6 mois c'estd
que la la le la diminution est de droit
mais pas la rétroactivité en revanche il
y a pas de raison de dire que parce que
pendant 6 mois on n pas mesuré il n'y
aurait plus aucun droit donc la l'avis
du Gouvernement est défavorable sur le
fond et sur et sur la forme merci madame
la ministre
pas de demande d'explication de vote que
ceux qui souhaitent adopter ses
amendements veut bien lever la
main merci avis contraire les
amendements ne sont pas adoptés le 60
rectifié bis
tombe pardon pardon monsieur
tendonné excusez-moi je je soutiens mon
amendement je crois que là aussi comme
tout à l'heure pour le contrat de
location fait référence à un état des
lieux type pour les quelques millions de
logements qui sont soumis à location me
paraît déçué je pense que avant que vous
ayez rédigé votre décret les les
bailleurs et locataires feront leur état
des lieux avec leur téléphone
portable merci monsieur le
rapporteur favorable pour les les mêmes
raisons que tout à l'heure effectivement
j'ajoute que le décret ne veut pas dire
est pas synonyme de absence de souplesse
donc avis desfavorable merci Madame la
Ministre quel est l'avis du Gouvernement
oui même avis que le rapporteur et même
avis tout à l'heure que que sur le bail
un outil de simplification de
clarification et de meilleur relation
entre propriétaire et locataire merci
pas de demande d'explication de vote que
ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veut bien lever la main merci
avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 151 est présenté par
Monsieur
doliget Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Madame le Ministre chers
collègues oui cet amendement qu'a
souhaité présenter notre collègue
Baumont et un certain nombre de de
collègues euh concerne la possibilité de
recourir à un huissier de justice qui
peut réaliser un état des lieux par
constat si les partis le souhaitent
alors nous rappelons qu'il y a en France
9 millions d'actes par an qui sont
réalisés par les hussers dont 500000 sur
des états des lieux or dans ce texte
particulier il y a eu à notre avis un
oubli puisque en l'état actuel de la
rédaction du présent texte
l'intervention de luuier de justice est
toujours prévu dans l'hypothèse d'un
conflit entre les partis au bail mais en
revanche ce projet ne prévoit pas
expressément l'intervention de la
profession dans le cadre d'état des
lieux dit amiable donc l'objectif c'est
de pouvoir compléter cette partie du
texte pour permettre aux huissers de
justice d'intervenir dans tous les cas
qu'il soi amiaable ou qu' ne soi pas
amiable merci chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur l'avis de la commission
moi je considère que le la demande de
Monsieur deblig est totalement
satisfaite par l'amendement qui a été
adopté
par la commission qui permet de dire
c'est l'alinéa 32 je crois qui permet de
dire que l'étatêre fait par des tiers et
pas seulement comme ça donc les tiers
c'est aussi entre autres unier de
justice il peut être fait aussi de façon
contractuelle par le le bailleur et et
le locataire donc pour moi c'est
totalement satisfait par l'amendement de
de la
commission merci Madame la Ministre
déforable oui avis partagé donc retraite
on défavorable merci chers collègues il
n'est pas
retiré monsieur le Président à partir du
moment où il y a eu la confirmation que
les huissiers de justice pouvaient
compte tenu de ce qui a été dit
précédemment effectuer
des des états des lieux amiables je vais
retirer l'amendement puisque bien
évidemment ça répond exactement à la
question qui était posée et si jamais
des remarques sont faites à des
huissiers dans ce cas-là bien on pourra
leur dire de se reporter aux engagements
qui ont été pris par le rapporteur et
par Madame le
Ministre collègue il est donc retiré le
361 rectifié présenté par Madame
Lamur merci monsieur le Président alors
la disposition de l'alinéa 35 que nous
proposons de supprimer prévoit que le
locataire après avoir intégré le
logement dispose d'un délai de 10 jours
pour demander à ce que l'état des lieux
d'entrée so a complété une fois les clés
remises au locataire et qu'il est entré
dans les lieux il en devient le gardien
et le logement est sous sa
responsabilité alors accorder au
locataire un délai de 10 jours pour
compléter l'état des lieux va poser des
problèmes de preuve et également des
contentieux et va déséquilibrer les
rapports entre propriétairees et
locataire c'est pourquoi nous demandons
la suppression merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de la
commission avis défavorable parce que
d'une part le bailleur n'est pas obligé
d'accéder à cette demande d'autre autre
part la charge de la preuve pèsera sur
le locataire s'il n'est pas en mesure de
prouver que l'état des lieux initials
était lacunaire la commission
départementale de conciliation ou le
juge prendra le parti du propriétaire
dans ces conditions la commission est
défavorable merci Madame la Ministre
l'avis du Gouvernement avis très clair
du rapporteur et partagé par le
gouvernement merci pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhait adopter cet amendement veut bien
lever la
main merci avis contraire l'amendement n
pas adopté l'amendement 367 rectifié
présenté par Madame Lamur oui alors
l'annexion du dossier de diagnostic
technique ne semble pas indispensable
dans le cadre des locations de meublés
touristiqu en effet ces contrats étant
conclus pour une durée limitée les
locataires ne sont pas exposés à des
risques importants par ailleurs de tels
contrats sont souvent conclus avec une
clientèle étrangère à qui nous ne devons
pas laisser à penser que le logement
présente des risques et en cette période
il semble que nous devions évit de
mettre en difficulté une activité
importante dans nos régions touristiques
les touristes sont déjà souvent
suffisamment déconcertés par notre
formalisme
administratif monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis de la commission avis défavorable
parce que je crois qu'il s'agit
pratiquement essentiellement que du
plomb je suis bien placé pour dire que
même si on va pas longtemps dans un
endroit mais qu'on y va souvent on peut
s'exposer au saturnisme donc je pense
qu'il est tout à fait normal que même
les touristes sachent s'il y a du plomb
ou pas donc avis défavor
merci Madame la Ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement oui c'est c'est une
disposition qui existe déjà qui est
rentrée dans l'usage donc il me paraît
pas utile effectivement comme il s'agit
exclusivement du plomb de supprimer C
disposition l'avis du Gouvernement est
défavorable merci pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement veul
bien lever la
main merci avis contraire l'amendement
n'est pas adopté trois amendements font
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 561
rectifié présenté par Monsieur monsieur
mzard merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues il
s'agit en fait de supprimer les
conséquences d'un amendement qui n'était
pas dans le texte initial du
gouvernement mais qui a été fait par
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale et qui
vise à compléter le dossier de
diagnostic technique annexé au contrat
de bail par une copie d'un état
mentionnant la présence ou l'absence
d'amiante et un état de l'installation
intérieure
d'électricité alors on ne peut
évidemment que partager les
préoccupations de l'auteur de
l'amendement concernant la sécurité et
la santé des locataires néanmoins nous
avons le sentiment et ça devait être le
sentiment je suppose initial du
gouvernement qu'on fait de la surenchère
et qu'on impose des standards à tous à
toutes les locations pour répondre à des
situations qui ont été certes à
l'origine de dérivve ou d'accidents
dramatiqu mais ne sont pas fort
heureusement la généralité la CRÉ tion
d'un contrat de location type ou d'un
modèle type d'état des lieux ainsi que
la multiplication des diagnostics sont
de ces standard nous n'y sommes pas
hostiles par principe ils peuvent être
plutôt sécurisants à la fois pour les
locataires et les bailleurs mais il
convient de prendre garde car plus on
ajoute à ce qui existe plus on va
dérouter décourager les petits
propriétaires je pense à ceux qui un
studio deux pièces qui louent il n'en
ont qu'un hein
qui souvent n'ont qu'un bien en location
qui entretiennent de bonnes relations
avec le locataire du jour au lendemain
ils vont se retrouver devant une
véritable usine à gaz et des coûts
supplémentaires pour parfois de tout
petits loyers est-ce vraiment
nécessaire de rendre obligatoire un état
mentionnant la présence ou l'absence
d'amiante un état de l'installation
intérieure d'électricité avec le coût
que ça représente la loi dit mol en plus
a renforcé les droits des locataires en
prévoyant la possibilité pour ces
locataires de saisir le service communal
d'hygiène et de santé ou l'agence
régionale de santé lorsqu'il considèrent
que l'installation électrique de leur
logement est en mauvais état la
collectivité dans ce cas peut engager
des travaux d'office au frais du
propriétaire par ailleurs les
obligations du bailleur en matière de
dessence sont claires vis-à-vis des
risques manifeste pouvant porter
atteinte à la sécurité physique ou à la
santé et le projet de loi vient
renforcer toutes ces dispositions nous
considérons nous qu'en complexifiant les
démarches des
propriétaires en particulier des
propriétaires qui n'ont que un ou deux
biens à louer on va finalement rendre
laborieuse difficile la gestion directe
locative et indispensable le recours au
professionnels de l'immobilier plus les
charges et les coûts je n'avais pas le
sentiment que cela était l'objectif
initial du gouvernement c'est pourquoi
cet amendement propose de s'en tenir
existant à savoir le diagnostic de
performance énergétique le constat de
risque d'exposition au plomb et dans
certaines zones l'état des risques
naturels et technologiques et c'est déjà
pas
mal merci chers collègues les deux
amendement 323 324 sont présentés par
Monsieur courte
oui monsieur le Président selon le
Conseil national de la consommation
chaque année on dé nombre 4 20000
incendies domestiques liés à des
installations électriques 7 millions de
logements présentent des risques et 2,3
millions ont des installations
électriques qualifiées de très
dangereuses le CNC a fait des
propositions pour remédier à cette
situation et l'une d'entre elles au
moins a été suivie d' fait ainsi les
propriétaires ont obligation de réaliser
un diagnostic électrique reposant sur
six points de sécurité en préalable à
toute vente de logement si
l'installation électrique du logement à
plus de 15 ans par contre aucune
obligation de produire un diagnostic
n'est fait pour les logements destinés à
la location alors que selon la loi de
1999 il y a obligation pour le bailleur
de remettre au locataire un logement
décent susceptible de ne pas porter
atteinte à la sécurité du locataire
cette situation a pour conséquence de
mettre les locataires dans une situation
de moindre sécurité par rapport aux
propriétaires par cet amendement je
propose de préciser la notion de
logement descent et je suggère que pour
tout logement don l'installation
électrique réalisé depuis plus de 15 ans
le bailleur devra produire une
attestation de conformité
de son installation avec les six points
de sécurité dont je parlais à l'instant
de plus par cet amendement il s'agit de
contraindre le bailleur à mettre à
disposition du locataire un logement ne
présentant aucun danger du point de vue
de l'installation électrique et le 324
monsieur Corto
oui on pourrait considérer que c'est un
amendement de repli car cet amendement
vise au renforcement de l'obligation de
sécurité
toujours dans le cadre d'un bail en
complément des dispositions votées à
l'Assemblée nationale mais je précise
que cet état de l'installation
intérieure d'électricité a pour objet de
contrôler que cette installation répond
aux caractéristiques du logement des
sang relative à la mise en sécurité
électrique le document de diagnostic
électrique opposable au bailleur et
annexé au contrat de bail lui permettra
de contrôler le respect de l'obligation
de mise à sécurité du logement qui
reposera sur le respect des six
exigences minimales telles que
préconisées par le CNC dans son avis du
27 septembre 2005 quant au document qui
ferait état du manquement à ces exence
minimale il contribuerait alors à
reconnaître l'incidence du logement par
la commission départementale de
conciliation ou par le juge qui pourront
être saisis en application des articles
20 et 241 de la loi du 6 juillet 1989
cela répond aux besoins de renforcement
de la sécurité physique des locataires
en réduisant les risques d'incendie et
d'électrisation et cela répond aussi au
besoins de sécurité juridique des
bailleurs collègue monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission sur l'amendement de Monsieur
Bard la commission pense qu'il n'est pas
choquant bien au contraire que le
locataire connaisse la présence
d'amiante ou l'absence d'amiante et le
diagnostic électrique vous dites
vous-même que il peut y avoir une
saisine de la commission de conciliation
mais pour qu'il y ait cesine pour savoir
si c'est un logement descent il est
important que le locataire soit informé
très clairement de l'état du du logement
euh d'autre part euh le je vais mettre
ça en parallèle avec les deux
amendements qui viennent c'estàdire que
en ce qui concerne votre l'amendement
que vous voulez supprimer enfin les
Lania vous voulez supprimer le
diagnostic peut simplement être une
copie d'un diagnostic qui a été fait au
moment de de l'achat donc il s'agit pas
d'un diagnostic supplémentaire alors que
en ce qui concerne l'amendement les deux
amendements monsieur Courteau j'ai aussi
un avis de retrait ou défavorable dans
la mesure où là il s'agit véritablement
je ne vois pas monsieur Courteau mais
voilà pardon je VO
pas il s'agit là d'un diagnostic
extrêmement lourd de conformité en six
points qui est à la charge du du
bailleur et donc qui est très très lourd
quant à l'amendement dit de repli je je
le trouve aussi lourd puisque là on
change de philosophie puisque là ça
devient un document opposable alors que
normalement les diagnostices sont
simplement des documents d'information
donc sur ces trois amendements je
demande le retrait ou à défaut avis
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre l'avis de la
commission du gouvernement
pardon
oui alors en fait les ces trois
amendements portent sur la même
disposition vous l'avez noté monsieur
mzard apporté au projet de loi en lors
du débat à l'Assemblée nationale
monsieur mzard souhaite supprimer les
États amiant et le diagnostic électrique
quant à Monsieur courtau et souhaite lui
que les choses aillent dans un sens de
de renforcement en tout cas vous avez
rappelé des chiffres qui sont des
chiffres effectivement qui interpellent
le gouvernement
250010 par an une grande partie d'entre
eux causé par des défaillances de
l'installation électrique 600 à 800
personnes qui perdent la vie et nous
avons des ratios qui sont deux fois plus
élevés que d'autres pays européens je
tiens à le rappeler parce que c'est un
un combat de longue date en ce qui
concerne la minist que je suis
l'installation des détecteurs de fumée à
divisé par deux dans l'ensemble des pays
c'est une loi qui avait été adopté dans
la par la précédente majorité les
victimes des incendies donc euh comme
comme l'ind qui est le rapporteur
monsieur mzard il s'agit de la
transmission des états existants et ce
qu'on a pu constater c'est que
l'existence du diagnostic électrique
avait en général conduit de façon assez
naturelle alors même qu'ils ne sont pas
obligatoires les acquéreurs à réaliser
des travaux de mise en sécurité
électrique là il s'agit simplement de la
transmission il ne s'agit pas d'une
obligation comme l'a dit le rapporteur
des documents qui existe déjà qui pour
les vent récente existe de manière
naturelle euh c'est pourquoi je je
solliciterais euh un retrait de votre
amendement de la même manière monsieur
Courteau vous vous allez beaucoup plus
loin il m'a paraît que là pour le coup
nous sommes de nature à engager des
frais supplémentaires important pour la
mise en location puisqueelle s'agit de
document reproduit à chaque à chaque
mise en location en conséquence de quoi
je propose de rester à la position qui a
été adoptée qui est va plus loin que la
situation existante mais qui ne franchit
pas le le pas que votre amendement
propose de franchir donc l'avis du
Gouvernement et la demande de retraite
ces trois amendements et à défaut un
avis fvorable merci Madame la Ministre
alors nous sommes sur le 561 rectifié
pas de demande d'explication de vote que
ceux qui souhaitent oui monsieur jarier
oui monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre chers collègues juste sur le
sur cet amendement la question de de de
l'amion pose quand même un problème
c'est que si effectivement il y a un
inventaire qui est fait qui a qu'on
explique qu' a une présence d'amion il y
a un risque aussi pour le bailleur de ne
pas pouvoir louer ce ce ce logement or
or or la présence d'amiante
contrairement à à un problème de
nonconformité d'un installation
électrique ne pose aucun problème dès
lors que c ces installations ne sont pas
ni ni bouger ni en mouvement c'est que
lors de travaux que ça peut poser
problème donc dans dans énormément de
logement il y a des toitures qui sont il
a des toitures qui sont en en amiante il
y a des sols qui sont en amiante et pour
autant il y a rien qui empêche la
location moi je crains simplement que la
disposition relative à laamante risque
d'aller à à l'inverse de ce qu'on veut
c'est que effectivement il risque d'
avoir une difficulté de location à alors
même qu'il n y a aucun risque en l'état
pour cette location donc moi je je suis
assez d'accord sur le le le évidemment
le le problème de la de la conirité de
l'installation électrique mais
s'agissant de la miante je pense qu'on
va trop loin qu'on va empêcher la
loocation de logements qui peuvent être
loués en pleine
conformité merci je j'ai à la fois
Monsieur rapporteur Madame le Ministre
madame la
ministre très rapidement pour vous
répondre justement ça n'empêche pas la
mise en location vous avez parfaitement
raison il est un sujet par exemple qui
est les revêtements de sol qui tant
qu'ils ne sont pas percé ou cassé ne
présente absolument aucun risque mais
justement l'information du locataire sur
la spécificité du revêtement de sol
existant puisque ça figure dans dans le
dans le rapport il saura que il faut
éviter de percer ou de fracturer les
dalle du revêtement de sol donc pour
répondre à votre question de manière
plutôt inversée ça permet une meilleure
information du locataire sur des
pratiques à ne pas avoir étant donné la
présence d'amiante qui ne présente pas
de risque puisqu'elle est incrustée si
je puis dire dans dans le revêtement de
sol mais qui risque de se retrouver en
suspension dans l'air si jamais ce
revêtement de sol est percé ou brisé
donc je pense que cette information est
utile justement pour éviter de mauvais
pratiqu sur ce type de revêtement de sol
par exemple pour répondre à votre
question merciadame ministre alors nous
sommes donc sur le 561 rectifié pas
d'autres demande d'explication de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter ve bien
lever la
main merci avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
ce 32
il est retiré monsieur cour
non non je l'Assemblée nationale a prévu
effectivement l'annexion d'un État à
l'installation au contrat de bail mais
que se passera-t-il en cas de non
présentation de l'état
ou si l'état produit est négatif
c'est-à-dire s'il révèle le caractère
dangereux voire très dangereux de
l'installation électrique c'est une
question que je pose pensez-vous que
cela stoppera la location pensez-vous
vraiment que là où il y a pénurie de
logement le logement ne sera pas mis en
location dès lors des familles entières
avec enfants seront en danger dans des
appartements où les règles de sécurité
des installations électriques ne seront
pas respectées je le redis le texte voté
à l'Assemblée nationale ne va pas
suffisamment loin il ne répond pas à la
question suivante le propriétaire d'un
logement qui présente une installation
électrique dangereuse sera-t-il
contraint de réaliser les
travaux question réponse non rien ne l'
obligera alors que se passera-t-il la
loocation se fera malgré tout et la
famille s'y installera à ses risques et
périls monsieur le Président moi je veux
bien faire un
pas vers madame la ministre et vers le
rapporteur je veux bien supprimer l'
pardon retirer l'amendement 323 mais je
maintiens le
324 alors le 323 est donc retiré dans ma
direction Mame et sur le 324 pas
d'autrre demande d'explication de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter veuent
bien lever la
main merci avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
deux amendements identiques font l'objet
d'une discussion commune l'amendement
160 est présenté par Madame
sech euh oui monsieur le Président le
présent amendement vise à supprimer la
possibilité d'introduire dans le contrat
de location une clause prévoyant des
pénalité pour le retard de paiement des
loyers et charges cette disposition est
triplement paradoxale et l'ensemble des
association défense des locataires la
conteste fortement premièrement l'un des
objectifs du projet de loi est bien le
renforcement de la prévention des
expulsion locativ notamment par un
encadrement des loyers dans les zones
tendues afin de limiter la charge
financière liée au logement pesant sur
le budget des ménages instaurer des
pénalités de retard va à l'encontre de
cet objectif puisqu'elles viendront
creuser les dettes des ménages qui sont
déjà en difficulté et rendront ainsi
plus incertain leur maintien dans le
logement deuxièmement l'adoption de
cette disposition a été justifiée par la
nécessité de donner une contrepartie au
bailleur face à la Léa morale que
représenterait la garantie universelle
des loyers or celle-ci vise précisément
à indemniser les bailleurs en cas d'un
payer de loyer enfin troisièmement et ce
n'est pas le moindre de telles clauses
sont considérés comme abusives par la
Commission des clauses abusives certes
la commission des affaires économiques a
encadré cette mesure la réduisant
réduisant le montant de la pénalité à 5
% du montant total des loyers charg du
permettant ainsi d'éviter toute
évolution exponentielle des pénalités
elle a supprimé également la spécificité
prévue par les députés pour le loyer du
dernier mois mais nous continuons de
demander purement et simplement leur
suppression merci chers collègues
l'amendement 562 rectifié est présenté
par Monsieur mzard Merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre cet
amendement va dans le même sens que
celui qui vient d'être défendu il vise à
supprimer la possibilité d'inscrire au
contrat de location une clause prévoyant
des pénalités pour retard ou non
paiement cette possibilité
elle existe aujourd'hui et il est vrai
que certains administrateurs de bien en
font un usage parfois abusif y compris
quand il n'y a pas de condamnation par
le juge civil c'est pourquoi le projet
de loi initial voulait les interdire
l'Assemblée nationale a souhaité
réintroduire ces clauses pénales pour
nous ditons diminuer les risques d'aller
à morale que la mise en place de la
garantie universelle du logement
pourrait générer et garantir le juste
équilibre du texte s'agissant du premier
argument j'oserai dire que c'est déjà un
aveu sur le risque de dérive du
dispositif de l'agulle mais on reviendra
sur ce point à l'article 8 s'agissant de
l'équilibre en matière de droit et de
devoir du propriétaire et du locataire
on pourrait adhérer à l'argument il
serait pas en effet
illogique d'instaurer des pénalités de
retard parce qu'il est vrai que le loyer
est une des seules dépenses pour
lesquelles elle n'existe pas et que
certains petits propriétaires comptent
sur leur revenus locatif pour boucler
les fins de mois les locataires de
mauvaise fois sont de surcroix favorisé
par rapport à l'immense majorité des
locataires qui paient leur loyer Ruby
sur l'ongle et dans les délais mais dans
ce cas pourquoi dans le dispositif
projeté n'y a-t-il pas de réciprocité
entre la pénalité applicable au
locataire pour retard de paiement
plafonné à 5 % des sommes du et celle
applicable au bailleurs en cas de
nonrboursement du dépôt de garantie dans
les délais fixé à 10 % par mois de
retard c'est une Curie conception de
l'équilibre contractuel hein il y a deux
poids deux mesures quelle motivation
conduit à prévoir des niveaux de
pénalité différents pour finalement des
situations identiques en réalité aucun
de ces deux arguments ne nous convainc
si cette disposition est un geste de
bonne volonté à l'égard des
propriétaires qui se sentent stigmatisés
pour certains par ce projet de loi ce
n'est à notre sens pas le meilleur car
en voulant prévenir les mauvais
coucheurs on pénalise surtout les
ménages les plus fragiles le plus
souvent lorsque le loyer est payé avec
retard c'est que les locataires sont
confrontés à des difficultés financières
veut-on véritablement accentuer leurs
difficultés ajouter de la dette à leur
dette et le dispositif de laagul
couvrira-t-il d'ailleurs cette pénalité
point
d'interrogation merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur quel est l'avis
de la
commission alors ça a été dit à
plusieurs reprises effectivement nous
sommes dans une loi d'équilibre et où le
rapport entre les bailleurs et les
locataires doivent être écalibré
équilibré et je pense en particulier
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
monsieur mzard au petits petits
propriétaires petit ou pas petit
d'ailleurs qui se sont endettés qui
doivent payer tous les mois et qui sont
pénalisés parce que ils n'ont pas de
recette donc ça me paraît quand même une
chose importante à dire deuxièmement il
ne s'agit pas d'une inscription
automatique c'est une possibilité mais
il ne s'agit pas d'une inscription
automatique troisièmement et vous l'avez
aussi évoqué monsieur mzard dans la
situation actuelle il y a des indemnités
des des clauses pénales de 10 % ce qui
est
énorme c'est le droit
actuel enfin et moi je considère que là
aussi c'est un équilibre j'ai bien
compris votre argumentaire sur la gulle
mais nous en reparlerons mais moi aussi
je là je pense qu'il y a aussi un un
équilibre entre laagulle entre la
responsabilité de l'assurance et la la
responsabilité de ne pas payer ses
loyers j'ajoute que justement la Gul va
permettre de mettre en route les
procédures sociales pour que les
locataires non pas de mauvaise foi mais
de bonne foi puissent bénéficier
rapidement ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement puisse bénéficier
rapidement euh des procédures sociales
qui vont le permettre de ne pas
s'enfoncer dans la créance cela dit
effectivement moi je je vous rejoins
c'est la raison pour laquelle et je
remercie madame charge de l'avoir noté
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
Commission a diminué considérablement
euh les les pénalités qui avaient été
les clauses pénales pardon qui avaient
été euh faites euh lors de la lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale puisque j'ai je
suis passé à 5 % et effectivement j'ai
supprimé le le dernier euh loyer qui
était à 30 % ce qui me paraissait
effectivement énorme en ce qui concerne
le miroir si je peux dire entre une
locataire qui a une clause pénale et le
bailleur qui n'a pas de clause pénale je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord c'est pas
une clause pénale c'est une clause
légale mais nous demandons au
propriétaire 10 % qui ne qui ne restiue
pas la garantie nous lui demandons et là
aussi moi je vois un effet d'équilibre
nous lui demandons une pénalité de 10 %
par moin de retard donc il y a là
effectivement une une une forme
d'équilibre merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame déf madame la ministre quel est
la VI du gouvernement oui l'avis du
gouvernement qui a donc constaté le
choix qui a été fait en commission par
les sénateurs après le choix qui avait
été fait par les députés de plafonner
une disposition monsieur mard qui
existait déjà dans la loi mais qui
n'était pas encadré cet encadrement a
été resserré par les sénateurs le
gouvernement prend acte de de cette
disposition et donc est défavorable à
tout changement considérant que ça
participe d'un certain équilibre que
l'encadrement est une bonne chose et que
il serait étonnant euh que euh la
suppression totale de de cette
disposition n'envoie pas un signal qui
serait un signal contreintuitif comme je
l'ai dit le choix du gouvernement a été
celui de de l'équilibre en la matière
donc le gouvernement s'est référé à la
sagesse des députés complétés par la
sagesse des des sénateurs sur ce point
voilà merci Madame la Ministre alors
nous votons sur les deux amendements pas
d'explication de vote madame
church
je regrette madame la ministre parce que
pour deux raisons d'abord pourquoi des
pénalités enfin imposer des pénalités
alors que vous proposez un système de
garantie universelle des loyers donc qui
va compenser les propriétaires bailleurs
donc c'est c'est pas un très bon signal
et c'est un très mauvais signal en
direction des populations les plus
fragiles qui sont dansiculté aujourd'hui
terrible et nous parlons bien de projet
de loi sur le logement et de garantir
également le pouvoir d'achat et et faire
en sorte que ces familles puissent s'en
sortir par le haut et je trouve que les
accabler encore d'une pénalité c'est pas
un bon signe su était l'inverse
c'est-à-dire puisque nous avons laagulle
et bien nous enlevons les pénalité et
effectivement nous faisons une démarche
d'accompagnement pour que ces familles
puissent
retrouver se se ressortir de de de
mauvais pas je je regrette mais je
maintiens mon
amendement merci pas d'autre demande
d'explication de vote nous votons donc
sur les deux amendements que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuilleent bien
lever la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre veut
bien lever la main l'amendement les
amendements sont
adoptés en arriv au 55 rectifiés bis
présenté par Monsieur Dalier merci
monsieur le président madame le minist
mes chers collègues cet amendement
propose de faire en sorte qu'il soit
impossible sur un bail loi 89 d'imposer
au locataire en surplu du paiement du
loyer un loyer d'équipement alors je
m'explique tout cela vient d'une
expérience personnelle assez
particulière il y a 2 ans j'ai dû
rechercher un logement étudiant du côté
de Melin et j'ai trouvé une résidence a
priori résidence étudiante je vous ferai
passer les documents Madame le Ministre
ça vaut le coup d'œil qui avait toute
l'apparence d'une r d'une résidence
étudiante classique gérée par l'OSE
association étudiante abus non lucratif
figure sur la plaquette le logo de la
région Île-de-France donc des garantie
absolue en terme de respect de la loi
sur la plaquette sont décrits les
logements tout va très bien et il est
également indiqué que les logements
disposent d'un lit avec saummier d'un
bureau une penderie une étagère un
tabouret deux chaises on parle
d'équipement collectif dans la résidence
et on nous dit qu'il y a un bureau
d'accueil pour l'intendante très bien
une laverie mais tout est payant une
salle de travail un local vélo et des
places de parking en extérieur et un
accès Wifi qui est payant jusque là rien
de très étonnant on nous parle ensuite
de prestation là on sait plus très bien
de quoi on parle et on nous dit que le
loyer inclut la mise à disposition des
mobiliers ça commence à devenir un peu
compliqué la la consommation d'eau et le
chauffage du studio les frais
d'électricité et d'eau pour les parties
communes la mise à disposition du local
vélo les frais d'entretien normaux de la
ventilation mécanique ça c'estz étonnant
l'entretien du matériel de sécurité et
de l'interphonie je sais pas très bien
si tout ça sont des charges locative
mais je je me permets d'en douter enfin
ceci étant dit je m'y rends et je
demande à ce qu'on me montre le bail et
là à ma grande surprise on me propose un
bail loi de 89 loi de 89 pour 6 ans
alors je dis tiens c'est quand même
bizarre est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer ça la jeune femme qui était
là et qui faisait des heures j'allais
dire pour arrondir les fins de mois éta
incapable de me répondre et donc je lis
loyer conventionné mensuel 322,73 €
loyer d'équipement nous y voilà 123,86 €
provision surchge 156 € cotisation
mensuelle à l'association obligatoire
9,15 € par mois total 612 € par mois
pour 30 m² 20 € du M Carr en pleine zone
industrielle de Melin
pour un studio destiné à un étudiant
alors je fais un mail et je pose des
questions et je n'ai pas de réponse et
au bout d'un mois on m'écrit et on me
répond je vous l'il met je vous le
transmettrai parce que ça vaut quand
même le coup d'œil monsieur vous avez pu
visiter et cetera il semble que vous
avez des questions dès lors nous
souhaitons vous apporter des précisions
l'immeuble a été construit par une SAA
HLM et pris à bail à construction par
l'onle cette construction a fait l'objet
d'un conventionnement l'État et le
propriétaire permettant aux occupants de
bénéficier d'un loyer modéré et de
l'aide personnalité personnalisé au
logement dans le casre de sa prise à
baille notre association doit respecter
les engagements pris par le propriétaire
des lieux c'est le cas notamment de la
soumission obligatoire des logements aux
dispositions de la loi de
89 la résidence étant par ailleurs
destinée aux étudiants
elle doit bénéficier d'équipement
spécifiques à ce type de logement vous
m'excuserez mais je les ai pas trouvé
les équipements spécifiques le tabouret
peut-être effectivement ou alors ce qui
relève des LO des LO comun résidentiel
dans tout bâtiment HLM ces
investissements concernant tant dans les
partis privatives que dans les partis
commune avec la création d'espace de
convivialité tu parles et alors là
accrochez-vous bien Madame la Ministre
le représentant de l'État autorise le
gestionnaire à mettre en place un loyer
des équipements en contrepartie de ses
investissements pour permettre la
réalisation de logements sociaux pour
étudiants objectifs prioritaires en Île
de France cette nécessité de créer des
logements sociaux se confirme chaque
jour puisque nous refusons de nombreuses
demandes ud en quête de logement qui
doivent se réorienter vers le marché
libre fort coûteux à 20 € du mètre carré
dans la zone industrielle de Melin vous
m'excuserez j'ai eu du mal à l'avaler et
ça se termine je vous le donne en
1000 vous comprendrez que la liste
d'attente s'allonge ainsi compte tenu du
temps écoulé notre association a dû
satisfaire à la demande de nouveaux
candidats et donc vous ne pourrez pas
disposer du logement étudiant en
question madame la ministre j'avais
transmis le dossier à votre prédécesseur
il s'est rien passé mais je je crois
qu'on est là dans l'abus manifeste je
vais réduire je termine monsieur le
Président mais franchement on est dans
l'ABU manifeste on prend le bail loi de
89 parce que comme ça lorsque les
étudiants au mois de juin quittent
peut-être le logement bah ils vont payer
le prêt àis on met des meubles mais
c'est pas un meublé on facture des
prestations qui ne sont pas des
prestations les appel équipement on est
dans la confusion des GES la plus totale
madame la ministre donc je veux vous
faire passer tous ces documents je vous
ai proposé un amendement je sais pas si
très bien si répond très bien à au cas
d'espèce parce qu'il vise à interdire le
loyer d'équipement dans ce cas-là ce que
je souhaiterais c'est qu'on l'adopte et
que dans la navette on traite le sujet
parce que des cas comme celui-là
croyez-moi que j'ai eu du mal à
l'avaler merci monsieur le rapporteur l'
VIIe de la commission oui le le sénateur
Dallier grâce à son expérience
personnelle soulève un lièvre
intéressant mais je je pense
qu'effectivement il peut y avoir un
loyer d'équipement je sais pas pour un
abonnement TV Canal Satellite et cetera
qui pourrait se faire aussi donc la
commission pense que c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant soulever et donne un avis
favorable à l'amendement merci Madame la
Ministre quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement oui la démonstration de
Monsieur daller comme dans un certain
nombre de cas est assez édifiante et le
le gouvernement a pour objectif
justement je l'ai dit dans l'utilisation
du travail parlementaire de faire le
point sur un certain nombre de Trappes
législatives que certains qui sans doute
étaient bien étent fondé au moment où
celles-ci ont été adopté mais qui ont
été détourné de leur fonction ce que
vous venez de de montrer le le démontre
assez bien donc laavis du Gouvernement
est favorable à votre amendement
merci alors je n'ai pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement veut
bien lever la
main et bien je vois il me semble il me
semble qu'on a
l'unanimité alors nous enchaînons sur le
129 rectifiés monsieur
Dallier faut pas
exagérer monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre alors là on est toujours sur le
bail 99 là aussi c'est mon expérience
personnelle mais de ma cette fois-ci
j'ai reçu par deux fois dans les
derniers mois des jeunes qui avait
réussi à trouver un logement mais à qui
l'agence avait imposé que l'un des
parents soit cocontractant du bail voilà
donc je pense qu'il faut essayer
d'éviter ce cas de figure alors là aussi
je sais pas si la rédaction de
l'amendement permettra à tout coup
d'éviter cela parce qu'évidemment le
choix est simple c'est un peu comme dans
le cas précédent c'est à prendre ou à
laisser donc beaucoup de parents et bien
finissent par dire ok je suis
contractant du bail alors qu'ils
auraient pu effectivement être simple
garant à à un moment donc je propose
l'amendement en question merci chers
collèguees monsieur le rapporteur l'avis
de la commission
oui là là aussi la Commission est
d'accord sur le fond puisque c'est il
s'agit d'un Abu manifeste simplement
elle soulève deux problèmes de forme et
un peu plus que de forme pour le premier
pour le premier problème c'est que là il
s'agit pas d'un contrat c'est dans le
contrat enfin ce que vous demandez ne
peut pas être dans le contrat puisque
voilà donc là il y a un problème de
forme c'est pas à cet endroit-là qu'il
faut poser cette question là même si la
réponse est oui donc ça c'est problème
de forme parce que c'est pas à
l'intérieur du contrat que qu'on peut
parler de ça par définition puisque
contrat et va être signé euh
deuxièmement euh ce qui nous empêche de
donner un avis défavorable mais plutôt
un conseil de retrait c'est que
inversement on ne peut pas ignorer qu'il
existe des situations où la signature
d'un ascendant ou d'un descendant euh
soit bénéfique pour tout le monde donc
en disant on on ne peut jamais on risque
aussi de contrecarrer des situations où
il faudrait donc je je propose moi le
retrait et qu'on en parle dans la
navette de façon à peut-être
mettre cette position de de meilleure
manière donc je propose le retrait à
défaut ce sera défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement avis identique à celui de
Monsieur le Rapporteur monsieur Dalier
effectivement le l'objectif que vous
poursuivez interpelle le gouvernement
qui y est sensible en revanche je pense
que la lettre de votre amendement
risquerait d'empêcher de manière
définitive des cignatures qui là en
revanche peuvent être voulu par
les locataires donc comme le le
rapporteur vous y invité je je soutiens
sa proposition retraite cet amendement
en vue de de du réexamen du problème
posé par votre amendement en deuxè
lecture merci Madame la Ministre chers
collègues merci le Président je pensais
mais je le vérifierai qu'on était dans
les clauses réputées non écrites donc
toutes celles qui impos au moment de la
signature donc effectivement si un
ascendant ou un descendant souhaite
signer il y a pas de problème là ici il
s'agissait de réputter non écrite toute
clause qui imposait bon s'il y a doute
je veux bien effectivement le retirer je
le fais mais je pense qu'il faut
effectivement éclaircir cela d'ici la
seconde lecture merci chers collègu neuf
amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune tout d'abord le 310
rectifié présenté par Monsieur
Marseille monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre l'activité des agents
immobiliers ne se limite pas à la
rédaction du bail ou de l'établissement
des lieux ils effectuent un certain
nombre de missions d'activités qui
appellent des rénumérations celle-ci
peut-être recherché soit auprès du
propriétaire comme le prévoit le présent
texte au risque de décourager certains
d'entre eux soit via le développement de
contrat de prestation de services
facturés au candidats locataire or sans
cet amendement les professionnels de
l'immobilier mandatés par le
propriétaire ne peuvent plus se faire
conférir un mandat de recherche par tout
candidat que locataire par ailleurs en
interdisant le mandat de recherche il
est possible que cela entraîne des
effets pervers avec des marchés
parallèle conséquence cet amendement a
pour objet de pouvoir permettre la
conclusion avec le candidat locataire de
convention de prestation de service de
recherche de bien
àoué chers collègues l'amendement 352
rectifié présenté par Monsieur
CALV le projet de loi va ajouter aux
difficultés que rencontrent les agents
immobiliers du fait de l'effondrement
des transactions si comme le propose le
projet de loi la rémunération des
personne mandaté pour laallocation d'un
logement est exclusivement à la charge
du bailleur ces derniers seront de moins
en moins nombreux à recourir à un
intermédiaire j'ajoute que les multiples
contraintes que ce projet de loi impose
au propriétairees va conduire à une
nouvelle contraction de l'offre de
logement dans le parc privé cet
amendement propose donc d'assouplir
votre dispositif quelque peu maniquen en
tenant compte des missions réalisées
au profit du locataire comme la
rédaction du bail ou l'état des lieux en
autorisant des mandats de recherche car
sur un marché qui se contracte il peut
être utile d'avoir recours à un chasseur
d'appartement surtout lorsque lorsqu'on
travaille voilà merci chers collègue
l'amendement 759 est présenté par
Monsieur dyin au nom de la commission
des Affaires
économiquesur président il s'agit
simplement d'un amendement coordination
avec une
renumérotation merci n avons deux
amendements identiques tout d'abord le
61 rectifié présenté par Monsieur
tandonet
oui monsieur le Président cet amendement
tente à partager les honoraires de
négociation de de l'agent immobilier qui
est souvent à la base de du
rapprochement entre bailleur et et
locataire je pense que si on ne partage
pas ces ces honoraires on va décourager
les les agents immobiliers de porter ce
ce genre de négociation et on va tarir
en partie euh le le nombre des logement
mis en location donc il me semble de
revenir à ce qui existait auparavant un
usage très ancien qui veut qu'on partage
ses
honoraires si le 342 rectifié présenté
par Madame Lamur oui monsieur le
Président bien comme le précédent cet
amendement vise à assouplir la
répartition des charges d'honoraire
entre le locatair et bailleurs ce qui
nous paraît équitable à défaut les
propriétaires seront moins nombreux à
recourir à des professionnels pour louer
leur bien en revanche le plafonnement du
montant des honoraires pour éviter tout
Abu nous paraît
légitime si le 492 rectifié présenté par
Madame lettard
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre chers collègues l'amendement
493 étant un amendement de conséquence
du 492 je l' présente entrer donc
ensemble il visent le même objet et donc
le même argumentaire de ce que mes les
précédents orateurs ont évoqué à savoir
le la répartition des honoraires sur
l'amendement euh que je présente en fait
il propose de maintenir la possibilité
de pouvoir conclure donc avec les
candidats locataires des conventions de
prestation de service de recherche de
bien loués dont la rémunération serait
indexé au niveau des loyers de serait
désindexé pardon du niveau des loyers et
qui pourrait être plafonné au niveau du
loyer médian de la zone dans laquelle la
prestation de service est rendue ce qui
permet de d'éviter les excès en ce qui
concerne la partie d par le locataire un
nombre de biens minimum fixés par décret
devrait être présenter au candidats
locataire de sorte à lui garantir un
service réel la prestation ne pourra
être facturée que si la recherche
débouche sur la signature d'un
bail l'amendement 161 présenté par
Madame Church
oui monsieur le Président donc cet
article premier vise à améliorer les
rapports entre les propriétaires et les
locataires cependant nous souhaiterions
amender l'alinéa 53 celui-ci limite les
services pouvant faire l'objet d'une
facturation répartie entre le locataire
et le bailleur ce qui est une bonne
chose actuellement compte tenu d'une
jurisprudence constante à partir de
l'article 5 de la loi de
1989 vous inscrivez dans la loi et c'est
une bonne chose que les frais de
rédaction de bail sont partageables mais
en plus vous ajoutez les frais engagés
par le bailleur à l'occasion de la
réalisation de l'état des lieux or le
bailleur n'engage alors ses frais que
pour assurer la défense de ses propres
intérêts et pour s'éviter un déplacement
sur les lieux il n'a donc nullement
obligation à notre avis de mandater il
n'a pas l'obligation de mandater une
agence pour se faire donc nullement
l'obligation d'engager ses frais il n'y
a donc pas lieu à notre avis d'imputer
ses honoraires au locatair même pour
partie aussi cette amendement par cet
amendement nous vous proposons de
supprimer à l'alinéa 53 la réalisation
de l'état des lieux afin que les frais
engagés par le bailleur à ce propos ne
soi pas un coût partager avec le
locataire mais simplement à la charge du
bailleur chers collègues le 563 rectifié
présenté par Madame
Laborde merci Monsieur le présidentad
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
les alinéas 53 et 54 de l'article 1er
mettent à la charge exclusive du
bailleur la rémunération des personnes
mandatées pour se livrer ou prêter leur
concours à l'entremise ou à la
négociation d'une mise en location d'un
logement à l'exception des honoraires
liés à l'état des lieux et à la
rédaction du bail il s'agit de mettre
fin à un certain nombre d'abus les
locataires se voient en effet facturer
des frais d'agence représentant souvent
un mois de loyer voire plus
parfois sans aucune corrélation avec la
réalité du travail effectué dans les
zones les plus tendues notamment le
service rendu par le professionnel de
l'immobilier au locataire est souvent
assez limité le seul fait pour un
candidat locataire d'entrer dans
l'agence ou d'appeler pour une annonce
immobilière ne saurait justifier une
rémunération quelconque dans ces zones
il semble donc logique que ce soit le
propriétaire mettant un bien sur le
marché qui le rémunère cela n'exclut pas
des demandes particulières du locataire
pour lequel il peut toujours donner un
mandat de recherche comme le permet
l'alinéa 54 en revanche dans les zones
détendu notamment les zones rurales
c'est plus discutable la prestation de
l'agent immobilier est loin de se
limiter à la rédaction du bail et
l'établissement de l'état des lieux son
rôle répond à l'attente de nombreux
candidats locataires car la recherche de
logement à loué est souvent plus
difficile l'agent sélectionne des biens
adaptés à leurs besoins l des visites
qui nécessitent des déplacements souvent
plus importants évalue les aides au
logement l'interdiction de partager les
honesoraires de location entre le
locataire et le bailleur est une mesure
qui ne prend pas en compte la réalité de
cette prestation dans les zones
détendues les candidats locataires
risquent de souffrir d'une offre de
service réduite au minimum notre
amendement vise donc à permettre au
professionnel de l'immobilier dans les
zones détendues de percevoir une
rémunération du candidat locataire
lorsqu'ils ont conclu avec lui une
convention de prestation de service de
recherche de bien àoué que ces derniers
fasse l'objet ou non d'un mandat de
recherche de la part du propriétaire sa
rédaction n'est peut-être pas
satisfaisante mais nous souhations
porter ces éléments à votre atttention
madame la ministre nous sommes d'accords
qu'il y a eu des tarifs injustifiés et
excessifs une certaine opacité mais ces
mauvaises pratiques ne sont pas le fait
de tous les professionnels de
l'immobilier certains sont tout de même
consciencieux je vous remercie merci
chers collègu et le 493 rectifié a été
défendu monsieur le rapporteur quel est
l'avis de la
commission je crois qu'il faut revenir
au texte de loi qui est très
précis l'alinéa 53 qui à mon sens est
une avancée importante du proj de
loi dit que la réumération de l'agence
immobilière est à la charge exclusive du
bailleur et non pas comme c'était le cas
dans le droit actuel partagé entre le
bailleur et le
locataire seul de exceptions sont prévu
l'état des lieux et la rédaction du
bail et par ailleurs le montant imputé
au locataire ne peut être supérieur à
celui imputé au bailleur et doit être
inférieur ou égal un plafond fixé par
décret ça c'estalinéa
53 l'alinéa 54
précise qu'une
rémunération peut être mise à la charge
du preneur quand le mandataire
intervient
exclusivement au nom et pour le compte
du locataire j'ai bien dit
exclusivement et à mon initiative il a
même été précisé que le mandataire ne
peut toucher les honoraires que s'il y a
signature du bail pour éviter évidemment
des abus qu'on voit venir et même qui
existent déjà
la commission pense qu'il faut rester à
cet équilibre qui a été trouvé
elle va donc donner un avis
défavorable à tous les amendements qui
ne ne respectent pas cet équilibre en
terme de partage d'onoraire qui est
clairement exprimé dans la loi et elle
va donner aussi un avis
défavorable lorsque la le mandat
exclusif de recherche n'est plus
exclusif autrement dit ce ce que la
Commission veut éviter c'est que le
mandataire prenne des honoraires par
pour le bailleur parce que il va
rechercher un locataire et prennent des
honoraires pour le locataire parce qu'il
va
rechercher une location et que il va y
avoir double commissionnement donc la
chose est absolument interdite donc là
aussi c'est quelque chose de précis il
faut garder le caractère exclusif donc
monsieur le Président la Commission
donne avis défavorable à l'ensemble de
ces amendements merci monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement
oui je ne reprendrai pas ce qu'a dit le
rapporteur sur un certain nombre de
points euh l'avis du Gouvernement est
défavorable sur les amendements qui
visent à à remettre en cause la volonté
que porte le projet de loi à l'URE que
le flou qui existait sur le partage des
honoraires a laissé place à une
inflation de de ces montants ça c'est un
premier point l'avis du Gouvernement est
également défavorable à votre amendement
madame churge qui l'avise à supprimer
toute rémunération de la part du
locataire on peut entendre et je le dis
que la prestation de signature du bail
de rédaction du bail pardon et
d'établissement de l'état des lieux
profite aussi au locataire et que la
rémunération par les deux parties peut
aussi induire que le positionnement du
professionnel qui établissent ces
documents le fassent à titre très
professionnel mais on est ayant des
égards pour les deux parties ça c'est
donc avis défavorable sur les
amendements présentés en première partie
sur l'amendement de Madame Church quant
au à l'amendement numéro
492 de Madame léard et l'amendement
numéro 563 de Madame La Borde je pense
que vous posez des questions notamment
pour ce qui concerne les zones détendu
sinon on voit bien le la difficulté qui
mérite d'être réfléchie je le dis nous
avons aussi et et chacun sait très bien
que l'élaboration d'un d'un projet de
loi se se fait dans un climat la volonté
du gouvernement dans l'élaboration de ce
projet de loi a été un travail avec
l'ensemble des partis il y a eu ces
dernières semaines un ridissement très
très fort de la part des professionnels
de l'immobilier qui ont abouti à une
absence de dialogue que je regrette
parce que le sujet que vous apportez
c'est tout le le sens et l'utilité du
travail parlementaire vous en faites la
démonstration c'est bien qu'il y a
effectivement peut-être des pistes que
nous avons euh écarté alors même qu'il
aurait été utile de d'y réfléchir
notamment en zone détendue puisqu'on
voità bien qu'il y a une prestation de
service et la volonté du gouvernement je
le redis c'est de faire payer à son
juste prix une réelle prestation n ma
réponse à Madame Church tout à l'heure
mais ma réponse là est la même on
imagine très bien que si un
professionnel mène une recherche active
visite des appartements pour pouvoir
proposer faire des propositions qui
répondent à la demande d'un locataire
d'un candidat locataire cette ce ce
travail M mérite rémunération donc vous
voyez cette piste n'existait pas
jusqu'alors du fait de de de la
situation qui s'était créée moi je je le
dis avec beaucoup de franchises hein je
je suis extrêmement tranquille sur le
sens et le choix de l'orientation de ce
projet de loi je l'ai réaffirmé dans la
discussion générale en réponse à un
certain nombre d'amendements on peut
critiquer mais c'était notre volonté si
on veut s'attaquer à la racine de l'état
d'esprit de ce projet de loi évidemment
que la position du gouvernement sera
très ferme en revanche nous souhaitons
avoir une réflexion ouverte sur cette
question la manière dont dont vous
l'avez abordé madame l'étard et Madame
Laborde me paraît aller dans le bon sens
donc je vous proposerai le retrait de
ces amendements avec l'engagement de ma
part et je souhaite d'ailleurs que ce
puisse être fait avec les professionnels
dans un cadre qui serait un cadre de
dialogue retrouvé d'y réfléchir dans le
cadre de la deuxième lecture parce
qu'effectivement il y a là dans cette
idée une prestation dont on imagine bien
que si les candidats locataires
sohaitent bénéficier que celle-ci puisse
être remplie donc voilà ma proposition
et mon engagement avis défavorable sur
l'ensemble des des des autres
amendements pour les raisons que j'ai
indiqué demande de retrait sur
l'amendement 100 pardon l'amendement 492
et l'amendement 563 en vue de la seconde
lecture merci Madame la Ministre alors
nous sommes sur le 70 rectifié
explication de vote madame
lettard non plus tard non vous êtes vous
êtes sur le 310
rectifié pour ord alors on va y venir on
va y venir merci donc nous sommes sur le
310 rectifié pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veut bien lever la
main avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
sur le 352 rectifié pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veulent bien lever la
main le 352 rectifié merci avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
sur le
759 pas de demande d'explication de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter ve
bien lever la main pardon madame la
ministre nous avons échappé cet
amendement c'est un amendement de
coordination du rapporteur pour lequel
l'avis du Gouvernement est favorable je
suis navré je l'avais pas précisé
absolument donc sur le 759 avis de la
commission pas de demande d'explication
de vote que ceux qui souhait adopter
veut bien lever la main merci avis
contraire il est adopté le 61 rectifié
et le 300 42 rectifier pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veent bien lever la
main merci avis
contraire les amendements ne sont pas
adoptés nous en arrivons au 492
rectifiés je passe la parole à Madame
lard
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre j'ai bien entendu
votre
proposition qui est effectivement de
bénéficier de la navette parlementaire
pour pouvoir travailler et en tout cas
essayer de trouver des voies de
convergence sur une position qui vise à
faire en sorte d'entendre quand même les
risques qui sont évoqués par les agents
immobiliers sur deux points un d'abord
la difficulté et la désorganisation du
secteur que représentent ces agences qui
ont quand même aujourd'hui sur ce
secteur-là 400 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et avec une mesure
qui conduirait à la suppression de 10000
emplois d'agents de location si elle
était appliquée strict au sensu c'est
une réalité économique c'est un secteurc
économique à part entière c'est
effectivement l'analyse qui remonte
après on peut la juger d'une manière ou
d'une autre l'analyser d'une manière ou
d'une autre c'est quand même ce qui
remonte de la profession vous l'avez
dit on peut considérer que il faut
laisser le choix au client qui le
souhaiterait de pouvoir faire appel à un
agent immobilier pour leur trouver un
bien à louer que celui-ci dispose ou non
de ce bien en portefeuille mais avec des
mesures qui peuvent être effectivement
regardé de plus près mon souhait c'est
d'éviter les effets pervers et les
risques que pourrai entraîner et bien
cette vision un peu restrictive des
choses parce qu'on aurait des
professionnels qui pourrait aisément
mettre en place des structures
juridiques qui se feront consentir des
mandats de recherche dissocier du
gestionnaire avec lesquels ils auront
des liens juridiques ou capitalistique
par exemple bref des contournements de
la loi il y en aura beaucoup y compris
de marchand liste d'une façon ou d'une
autre qui pourrait revenir par des biais
détourner vous savez très bien que
l'inventivité est très grande dans le
domaine on trouve toujours les moyens de
contourner la loi donc Madame la
Ministre j'ai bien entendu qu'il fallait
retravailler les choses mais vraiment
l'idée qui était la nôtre c'était de
trouver le moyen de quand même faire en
sorte que les locataires puissent
contribuer mais d'une façon mesurée et
réglementée pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'abus en l'occurrence donc sur cette
base là j'accepte de retirer au nom de
mon groupe cet amendement sous réserve
bien évidemment de pouvoir y revenir en
seconde lecture d'une façon qui soit
encore une fois une bonne voie de
convergence merci chers collègues il est
donc retiré sur le 1 pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter ve bien lever la
main merci avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
sur le 563 rectifié est-il retiré madame
la B j'accepte de le retirer au nom de
mon groupe mais nous serons là bien sûr
en seconde lecture si vous n'avez pas
réussi à négocier comme vous le désirez
merci et donc le 493 rectifié est
également retiré madame lard
merci alors nous avons quatre
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 252 rectifié bis
avec un autre amendement identique il
est présenté par monsieur Dubois oui
monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre la loi crée des observatoires
locaux des loyers s'appuyant sur une
expérimentation d'un dispositif
d'observation des logements sur 19 sites
pilotes permettant d'observer un parc
d'environ
2600000 logement soit près de 40 % du
parc de logement locatif privé en France
cette expérimentation est est déjà en
cours en en revanche et comme j'ai bien
compris madame les ministre que vous
alliez réouvrir le dialogue avec les
agents
immobiliers donc comme la loi ne tient
pas compte dans l'état actuel de
l'existence d'un
observatoire alimenté par plus de 60 %
des
professionnels qui fonctionnent de
manière plutôt convenable he depuis plus
de 5 années
cet observatoire dénommé clameur mérite
à notre avis d'être référencé son
tableau de bord mise à jour chaque
trimestre propose une analyse détaillée
des évolutions intervenues depuis 1998
sur les marchés locatifs privés de 1242
villes regroupement de communes et pays
et de plus de 10000 habitants cet
amendement donc propose de laisser la
possibilité aux intermédiaires
professionnels de poursuivre
l'alimentation de cet observatoire selon
des proc procédures qui sont
opérationnelles et efficaces et de
prendre donc en considération des
données de l'Observatoire
clameurèg 309 rectifié bis présenté par
Monsieur
Marseille monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre effectivement je vais pas
reprendre ce que vient de dire mon
collègue Daniel
Dubois c'est exactement le le même souci
c'est c'est de tenir compte d'un
observatoire qui
effectivement alimenté par beaucoup de
professionnels qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi il est pas référencé donc je
crois que je me rangerai également à sa
conclusion puisque vous êtes proposé de
de poursuivre la discussion avec les les
professionnels peut-être serait-il
opportun d'inclure cet observatoire de
façon à ce qu'il ne soit plus écarté de
du texte
présenté merci chers collègues le 335
rectifié est
présenté par Monsieur Marseille
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
minist il s'agit d'un amendement de
cohérence parce que de nombreux
professionnels interviennent évidemment
lors de la conclusion d'un bail et il
est étonnant d'observer que le le
présent texte ne prévoit de sanction
qu'à l'encontre des professionnels
soumis à la loi du 2 janvier 70 lorsque
ces derniers ne communiquent pas
d'information à l'observatoire local des
loyers donc soit on sanctionne
l'ensemble des professionnels pour les
manquements concernant l'absence de
remontée d'information soit on nen
sanctionne aucun et c'est le choix euh
qui est porté par ce présent
amendement merci enfin le 359 rectifié
est présenté par Monsieur Lenoir oui
monsieur le Président nous proposons de
supprimer l'alinéa 59 en effet
rejoignant les interventions des
préopinants d'autres professionnels ont
des instances de contrôle et sont amenés
à intervenir dans la conclusion d'un
bail ou dans la gestion locative je
pense notamment au notaires aux
huissiers aux avocats et cetera et et
cette disposition nous apparaît tout à
fait discriminatoire envers les
professionnels qui sont soumis à la loi
du 2 janvier 70 dit loi au gu et jette
le discrédit sur toutoute une profession
il est donc proposé de supprimer cette
mesure alors j'ajoute une chose mes
collègues ont laissé entendre que madame
le ministre était d'accord pour engager
des négociations avec les professionnels
immobiliers et là-dessus madame la
ministre vous avez vu vous retournez
vers eux j'ai lu sur vos lèvres
pardonnez-moi de le dire mais j'ai
surtout entendu vous avez dit peut
pe-être il faudrait peut-être lever
l'ambigué de façon à savoir quelles sont
exactement vos
intentions merci chers collègues alors
je vais demander le l'avis de la
commission au
rapporteur alors sur l'amendement 252
rectifier bis j'ai bien compris monsieur
Dubois que vous faisiez allusion à à
clameur donc mais le fait de vouloir
exiger que tout remonte un
un observatoire national supprime des
facto les observatoires locaux qui sont
dans la loi donc déjà ce ce problème est
est n'est pas acceptable pour la
Commission et et donc nous allons
demander un avis favorable d'autre part
la création des observatoires locaux des
loyers n'entraîne pas la disparition du
dispositif clamur si la la ministre
souhaite travailler avec la profession
et avec clamer en particulier peut-être
que ça sera facilité si clamer euh
accepte de donner sa méthodologie je
pense que les choses pourraient
peut-être aller un petit peu mieux bien
entendu c'est pareil pour le
309 135 rectifié oui le 38 rectifié
non
non non 335 rectifié je l'ai
pas 38 et retir d'accord 335 alors
d'abord je je je pense qu'il s'agit
plutôt de l'alinéa 59 que de l'alinéa 58
euh donc que Monsieur notre collègue
HERV Marseille propose de de supprimer
cette alinéa je je ne vois pas très bien
pourquoi d'ailleurs parce que je ne vois
pas pourquoi on pourrait empêcher toute
personne intéressée de communiquer à
l'Observatoire des loyers les
informations relatives au logement donc
la vie est défavorable en ce qui
concerne le
359 rectifié qui pose un problème
effectivement
intéressant l'article 59 l'alinéa pardon
59 prévoit qu'en cas de manquement d'un
professionnel soumis à la loi ogog à son
obligation de transmission des
informations relatives au logement et au
contrat de location l'Observatoire des
des loyers l'Observatoire des loyers
peut saisir la commission de contrôle
régional ou interrégional instance
disciplinaire crée qui est créée par
l'article 9 de notre projet de loi donc
notre collègue Calvet propose de
supprimer cet alignéa la Commission a un
avis défavorable d'une part parce que il
est essentiel que les professionnels
transmettent leur information aux
observatoires locaux des loyers et
d'autre part notre collègue note que cet
alinéa ne concerne que les
professionnels soumis à la loi Ogay euh
en fait les autres professions qui sont
mentionnées sont des professions
réglementées qui ne sont pas soumis à la
loi au gai mais qui sont soumis à des
des des règlements de discipline et donc
forcément euh ces mêmes professionnels
qui ne relèvent pas de la loi auoget
pourrai également être sanctionné en cas
de non transmission mais selon les
règlements en vigueur merci monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement
oui euh je vais d'abord préciser sur les
la méthode de discussion autour de la
loi allure avec les uns avec les autres
moi j'ai assumer la position du
gouvernement comme je l'ai fait devant
vous quand j'ai expliqué à l'occasion
des autres projets de loi quel serait
l'état d'esprit du projet de loi àure
qu'il avait pour objectif la régulation
par l'encadrement des loyers
l'engagement numéro 22 de françois
hollande président de la République et
qu'il voulait aussi mettre fin à
certains abus des professionnels et vous
avez bien lu sur mes lèvres mais c'était
fait pour être lisible monsieur le
sénateur pour être pour discuter il faut
être deux et un certain nombre de
professionnels pas tous se sont enferrés
dans une attitude qui était une attitude
de confrontation assez stérile
finalement très brutale plus que
caricaturelle et vaguement insultante y
compris avec du matériel d'affiche et
cetera d'un goût
limité franchement ça ne m' pas empêcher
ni de dormir ni de me réveiller mais je
le
dis pour discuter il faut être deux et
cette d'ailleurs et l'on voit le vote en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
on voit le débat ici je pense que il y a
eu une une mauvaise estimation de la
part de certains d'entre eux de l'état
de l'opinion publique et des
parlementaires à l'égard de la nécessité
d'avancer sur un certain nombre de
sujets je pourrais me référer notamment
à un certain nbre de dispositions de ce
projet de loi qui était déjà qui
figurait déjà dans le projet de loi
relatif à la consommation de Frédéric
Lefèvre pourquoi parce que le manque de
réglementation et d'encadrement de des
professionnels a provoqué aussi le
développement de certaines pratiques le
développement d'une concurrence qui
était une concurrence à l'égard des
professionnels les plus sérieux de la
part de gens qui ont profité de la
situation du marché immobilier donc
voilà la situation dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons j'ai dit que j'étais
ouverte à la discussion comme j'étais je
suis ouverte à la discussion de manière
principielle monsieur le sénateur avec
tout le monde nous avons évoqué la
question du plui autant vous dire qu'on
est parti sur ce débat sur une position
encore plus douloureuse et difficile
puisqu'elle était notamment avec des
sénateur de la majorité que j'ai en
haute estime que avec des professionnels
qui doivent savoir que c'est bien
évidemment l'Assemblée et le Sénat qui
ont toute capacité et toute liberté pour
voter la loi donc je dis je suis dans la
situation d'être en permanence ouverte
au dialogue j'ai simplement constaté le
fait qu'un certain nombre de
professionnels se sont confis dans une
position que j'estime leur être
davantage nuisible le débat que nous
avons eu autour de l'amendement de
Madame lard et de Madame Laborde le
prouve puisque ces discussions n'ont pas
pu avoir lieu donc je vous dis peut-être
parce que je tiens un bout de l'histoire
ils en tiennent un autre je constate la
situation l'état d'esprit dans lequel
ils se sont mis et je le dis à tort
parce que une immense majorité de nos
concitoyens ont à l'égard de cette
profession là aussi sans doute à tort
mais du fait des excès de quelques-uns
un a priori qui n'est pas un a priori
favorable et donc cette position et ce
positionnement ne leur a pas crédité un
soutien massif dans l'opinion voire même
au contraire et je le dis ce ce climat
il ne m'appartient pas il ne
raappartient pas il est le résultat
d'une situation et danné de
décrédibilisation du fait des pratiques
et des abus de quelques-uns de
l'ensemble de la profession c'est une
situation qui me semble d'ailleurs pas
être une bonne situation parce que je
pense qu'il s'agit d'un domaine dans
lequel l'intervention de professionnel
est utile et que un rôle de médiation et
intermédiaire entre propriétaire et
locataire est très utile et que j'espère
et je le dis là ici que en baissant le
cou des prestations par le biais des
dispositions qui sont adoptées ce sera
j'allais dire favorable à ce que
l'activité se développe pas en valeur en
l'occurrence en augmentant le prix des
prestations mais en volume puisque la la
le meilleur accès à l'intervention d'un
professionnel qualifier la certitude que
ce sera utile pour le propriétaire comme
pour le locataire seront de nature à
valoriser ce travail mais je le dis je
je suis aussi pas dupe d'un certain
nombre nbre d'opérations de
communication un peu brutale qui ont eu
lieu ces dernières semaines néanmoins
rien ne me détournera de mon objectif la
régulation et là-dessus j'ai toujours
été extrêmement transparente je vous
renvoie à mon intervention lors de
l'assemblée générale de la FNAIM il y a
maintenant quasiment un an où j'ai dit
mot pour mot mot pour mot mot pour mot
ce que j'allais faire et quelle était ma
feuille de route mot pour mot et je suis
dans cette direction donc pour vous
répondre précisément sur ces amendements
et sur la question des observatoires
nous avons besoin d'observatoire solide
avec des données fiables avec une
transparence un Open Source si je puis
me permettre sur l'alimentation de ces
données ce qui n'est pas le cas de
clameur aujourd'hui et c'est pourquoi
nous avons à la fois fait confiance aux
collectivités locales aux acteurs locaux
pour mettre en place les observatoires
et mis en place un comité scientifique
pour que la collecte des données soit
extrêmement nor normalisé pour qu'on
puisse comparer ces données du nord au
sud de la France de de manière et dans
les outres m de manière extrêmement
fiable ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui je dois vous dire que
l'annonce je crois même quasiment le
jour même du début de la première
lecture à l'Assemblée du fait que les
loyers commençaient à baisser par
conséquence de quoi il n'y avait pas
besoin de l'encadrement des loyers à
créer sur mes lèvres un léger petit
sourire sur la manière dont on pouvait
utiliser des données pour alimenter une
position plutôt que pour être
extrêmement transparent sur la réalité
et l'utilité d'avoir des données fiables
en matière de logement et notamment de
niveau de loyer donc voilà je vous ai
répondu longuement ce qui me permettra
d'éviter de le faire sur d'autres sujets
voilà la position du gouvernement et la
mienne sur cette question de manière
claire ferme et transparente mon avis
est donc défavorable sur les amendements
252 309 335 et
359 merci Madame la Ministre donc nous
sommes sur les 252 rectifiab et 309
rectifi Bliss pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter ve bien lever la main
merci avis contraire ils ne sont pas
adoptés sur le 335 rectifié pas de
demande d'explication de vote qui est
pour merci qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté sur le 359 rectifié même
vote même
vote voilà donc pour la discussion
autour du projet de loi logement qui a
démarré hier après-midi et hier soir au
Sénat suite de la discussion et bien à
partir de cet après-midi à la Haute
Assemblée suite de la discussion autour
de l'article 1er de ce texte de Cécile
Dufflot nous vous proposons de la suivre
à partir de 16h30 cet après-midi sur
notre antenne à noter qu'il y a quelques
755 amendements qui ont été déposés
autour de ce projet de loi et que donc
la discussion devrait se poursuivre
toute la semaine et même jusqu'au
weekend compris très bonne journée à
tous sur l'antenne de public scénna et
donc à tout à l'heure
16h30
comment la Grèce berceau de la
civilisation et de la démocratie
a-t-elle pu entraîner dans sa chute
l'Europe tout entière quels sont les
mécanismes qui ont conduit le pays à la
faillite financière sans qu'aucun
partenaire européen ne réagissent etu de
l'leur de petits problèm on a décidé de
faire une étude approfond pour le cas
grec on arrête de jouer Ono de grâce à
des témoignages exceptionnels
reconstruisez le fil des événements et
la succession de décisions qui ont
produit cette crise sans
précédent crise grecque une faillite
européenne samedi à 22h sur Public
Sénat
ces images ont fait le tour du monde en
ce début de mois de juin le gouvernement
turc réprime violemment des
manifestations à Istanbul la défense
d'un jardin public menacé devient vite
un large mouvement de contestation à
travers le
pays le déclic pour une partie de la
population lassé par un pouvoir jugé
trop conservat
c'est le point de non retour ce qui se
passe ici va au-delà de la défense de
taximés il s'agit de défendre la liberté
en Turquie et ce sont des jeunes entre
18 et 30 ans parfois plus jeunes qui
sont en premère ligne il s'agit de
revendiquer plus de liberté de
démocratie et de droits de l'homme nous
résisterons au
fascisme les affrontements font
plusieurs victimes indignation de la
communauté internation
le pouvoir tur est appelé à plus de
retenu par ses partenaires comme le
Parlement européen qui condamne
officiellement la répression
policière colère des autorités
turques nous n'avons pas à recevoir de
leç sur ce genre de
problème depuis quelques temps les
membres du Parlement européen se
plaisent à regarder et observer la
Turquie d'un il occidental inquisiteur
et la repousse vers son
orientalisme façon de voir les
choses cette passe d'arme illustre la
dégradation des relations entre
Bruxelles et ancara si la Turquie a
longtemps attendu le miracle européen
elle parle aujourd'hui d'un
mirageul la plus européenne des villes
de Turquie un carrefour de culture pied
sur Vieux Continent et la tête en Asie
une ville moderne rebelle ici l'idée
d'une adhésion à l'Europe à ses
défenseurs comme safety gursell ce
professeur d'économie et de droit
européen se bat contre certains clichés
vu d'Europe la Turquie fait peur les
principaux dirigeants européens
dénoncent une islamisation rampante ce
n'est que des desou
l'islamisation de la Turquie par le
gouvernement pour le
moment il n a pas eu
comme je vous ai dit des des lois
islamiques l'introduction des lois
islamiques dans le Code civil et cetera
Israël par exemple on dit c'est un pays
démocratique et cetera Israël est
certainement beaucoup moins laïque que
la Turquie aujourd'hui c'est une peur
qui n'est pas fondée mais évidemment cet
avis n'est pas partagé par tous les
Turcs les premières discussions avec
l'Europe ont débuté dans les années 60
une longue procédure que SAF gursell
explique dans ses cours
le problème de la Turquie c'est pas
qu'il soit musulman mais qu'il soit trop
grand
euh dans le passé on disait aussi trop
grand trop pauvre maintenant on dit
moins trop pauvre étant donné la
situation en Europe et vu le progrès la
croissance en Turquie et cetera mais il
est trop grand il reste trop grand et on
n peut
rien en clair la Turquie dans l'Union ce
serait plus de députés que la France et
presque autant que l'Allemagne alors
trop grand ou trop musulman une chose
est sûre lassé d'attendre le pays se
tourne de plus en plus vers le Proche
Orient
ametxus a ses entrées à Bruxelles pour
ce chef d'entreprise si l'avenir de son
pays est à l'est il n'y voit pas un
frein à une
adhésion c'est important pour la Turquie
de s'imposer comme le pays phare de la
région
et d'un autre côté c'est tout aussi
intéressant pour l'Europe d'intégrer
dans l'Union la Turquie et son influence
locale une Turquie européenne
l'entreprise de mourtiasa en est une
parfaite illustration sa spécialité les
arô pour l'industrie
alimentire qui travaille dans cette
usine donc si vous voulez on est rentré
on a formé notre propre communauté
européenne ici avant de avant que la
Turquie s'adhère à à l'Union
européenne si la Turquie ne fait pas
partie de l'Union des accords existent
déjà en matière douinière ou comme ici
en matière sanitaire dans ces flacons
des centaines d'arômes tous aux normes
européennes alors l'adhésion à l'Europe
mouratiasa y croit il faut décider si le
c'est une Europe
eurocqueen c'est une Europe qui à partag
sesaleurs avec la
cand turie qui attend l'adion à
l' bazı Var da onlar
yüelce şy en tur le problème ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui c'est le N pas c tout
ça des choses comme ça moi je crois que
en turie il y a un problème de respect
humain si les C il souffr comm il dis en
Turquie les turc aussi souffrent ou bien
les je sais pas les tous les autres
groupes ethniques aussi qui vivent en
Turquie il souffr c'est du manque de
droit de l'homme en
turquieadhionunionar comme une garantie
pour l'avenir mais peu de gens y croient
encore la faute un double discours
permanent des dirigeants européens
dernier exemple en date lors de la
visite d'Angela Merkel nous sommes dans
un processus de négociation ouverte même
si j'ai des réserves sur la pleine
adhésion je tiens à garder les
discussions sur la bonne voie ces
déclarations ont des effets désastreux
dans l'opinion publique turque et
particulièrement parmi la jeune
génération dans un récent sondage 62 %
des 16 30 ans n'ont plus confiance en
l'Europe à la sortie de la grande
université d'Istanbul la question fait
débat pour beram et ses amis il y a du
pour et du contre on ne peut pas
vraiment le dire avant mais je pense que
nous devons intégrer l'Europe et ensuite
on verra
bien non non moi je ne veux pas je suis
contre l'entrée dans l'Europe je suis né
en Allemagne donc je sais ce que ça
signifie de vivre dans un pays européen
il y a la crise économique le chômage a
augmenté avec l'euro et perdu du pouvoir
d'achat je pense que la Turquie n'a pas
besoin de l'Europe au contraire c'est la
zone euro qui a besoin de nous je pense
que si on arrête les négociations
aujourd'hui c'est l'Europe qui viendra
frapper à notre porte ce processus a
vraiment été trop
long ce rejet est entretenu par les
médias turques souvent
euroscepti dans ce petit immeuble un
journal francophone fait